Hey, listen, a real quick before we get into this episode with the incredible Will Ferrell head like a moment of your time to set the stage a little bit. Now, Sean and Will and I, we went on a smart list tour last year where we recorded 10 episodes live in front of thousands of our biggest fans. This episode with Will Ferrell was the first of 10 and was recorded live in Washington, D.C. and guess what, right now there are more live episodes from our tour on One Dree Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free on OneDri Plus, after which
you can hear them for free wherever you get your podcast. Find OneDri Plus in the OneDri app or on Apple Podcasts. Are we in the cold open right now? We're in the show's helping right now. Okay, so the cold open is right now. We're about to do our first show. It's our first live show. What should we let people...
Let's pray to the podcast God. Okay, pray to the podcast God. What's bringing in? Is it him or her? It's all of them. So it's a day. It's everything. It's all of them. So it's a day. It's everything. It's everything.
It's everybody. It's a world of all-inclusive. Okay, what's the prayer? And the prayer is... Please Lord Pod. Pod. Pod person. Please shine your happy, funny, light, lovely light on our stupid, stupid idea to go live with this pod.
And welcome to the Smart List. Thank you. Washington DC, thank you for having us. Thank you for having us, this is... Yes. And please, above all things, manage your expectations. Yeah. Because this was really, you know, kind of a half a joke, and then we got an invite, and we said, well, maybe we should. Yeah.
But we want to make sure you guys understand. It's just the three of us talking to a person for an hour. Yeah, that's it. There's no... That's it. So, I hope you enjoyed it. Yeah. I mean, there's not going to be any singing, there's no dancing, there's no... We don't even know how to do it.
We sat down, we were backstage, and we were dicking around. Well, make sure you buy one of these. Yeah. Or four of them. Or four. But we were dicking around, We were doing Sing for Real backstage, and then Jason didn't want to do it, because he claims he can't sing.
I can't sing. I don't even sing a shout. You get to know about Sing for Real that we talked about, right? And you guys, have we talked about? No, I don't think so. So tell him what it is. So Sing for Real is, it started a long time ago,
one of the big enemies of the podcast, Justin Thro, JT from New York. He did this bit where we would sing in the car and then he'd say no, sing for real, which means you can't do it as a bit, you can't like embellish, you can't go to a show me, and you can't like do it like that, you have to do it for real. Like sing the best you possibly can.
And it's so embarrassing. Yeah, it's so embarrassing. So will sing for real. But you sing for real, you've done Broadway. No, I like when Will does it. So, will sing for real. No, I'm saying you know how to sing for real. You're gonna sing for real now?
Yeah, you have to sing for real. Give me a song, any song. What is it? Don't stop believing, don't stop believing. Oh yeah, what are the lyrics? Just don't stop believing. Believe in, hold on to that sweet. By the way, it stops here.
We're not going around. Hold on to that sweet by the way it stops here. We're not going around Hold on to that sweet free feeling. Yeah, okay ready but now but now he can't do a bit I can't do it. I can't do it. I can't it. Yes to really sing it really like he's really looking fucking focusing It's the worst Okay, go. Okay ready three two go. Don't stop, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom He's doing it in bed. Oh, oh! All right. All right, so wait, listen. Have you, now have you ever done any musical theater? No way. No, I'm pretty sure that just costs us about $150,000.
We're not going around. Hold on to that sweet by the way it stops here. We're not going around Hold on to that sweet free feeling. Yeah, okay ready but now but now he can't do a bit I can't do it. I can't do it. I can't it. Yes to really sing it really like he's really looking fucking focusing It's the worst Okay, go. Okay ready three two go. Don't stop, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom He's doing it in bed. Oh, oh! All right. All right, so wait, listen. Have you, now have you ever done any musical theater? No way. No, I'm pretty sure that just costs us about $150,000.
I know. Okay, so wait, now listen, we flew and I've only been to DC once before. I loved it, but I was here very briefly. Sean, why don't you just relax and get casual and cross your legs a little bit? So we, uh, we, uh, we, uh, and so we were at phone out here. What am I going to do? You brought your phone?
I, I, listen, I, I'm a doctor. We were driving in from the airport yesterday, and I said I wanted to know where a specific thing was which was I went a Land or no you were driving along and there's some some park land or whatever and go and Sean Seriously said is that where the grassy noles or was it Not a bit Could not be less smart.
So I really didn't know if I'd... Then you explained it. Were we shocking how little both of you knew about anything? That was a real shock. Yeah. Well, he didn't know. I bet you guys were... This came from the
Washington Monument this was this this this started your claim This whole Simple start giving it to them for sure. Yeah, no There's a great. There's a still because it was it was a statement on stage in DC immediately gives a crowd It's a big it's a bit it was a big FU back to Europe That we made it we did it and look we got a monument now and that's true. I don't know if that's true. It's not I forgot we didn't really close that up at it. I had him kind of going out on the sidewalk,
and then we went on to something else, and he literally just tried to get the real answer just now. By the way, it should be in your defense. This is coming from the guy who all you're faxillately are from Maple. Right, Maple, my 10-year-old daughter spends a lot of time on YouTube because it cuts down on my parenting obligations. She, when you say to an actor,
oh, break a leg. I've always thought it's you wish the person and my apologies to people over here. You, you say break a leg because now only a good thing can happen, right? That was, she says no daddy break a leg means if you break your leg you you get put in a cast and that's what you're trying to do when you audition to get put into a cast and that's where it comes from. No, don't don't. Don't I it's too many faces going no way.
Yeah, here's the going no way. Yeah. Here's, they're all turning to each other. Here's the best part, and then he goes, and then he's, and I said, well, maple, when she get that, and he goes, YouTube. Like, it's if it's like, oh, oh, from the news. I see. Also, also, where all the facts come from. Also, sand is called sand because it's neither sea nor land.
Right? Look, they're all looking at their neighbor. I don't know. Yeah. I don't know. Let's verify it. I think it's real. But here's the other thing that happened today that I've never done.
A day of first was we were walking, Jason wanted to walk. Maybe another extra 25, 30 miles. And all of a sudden, you were here. Jason said, why don't we take one of those birds? And I said Marty Bird. And then he slapped me really hard enough. But I never, and I was like, you guys go, this is too complicated. Like, how do you undo the thing and I got to sign up? And the app, he, Jason did it for me. We rode these birds all around town today. It was the best time I ever had. Yeah.
We took the bird from the Washington Monument to the Capitol, and then here to the arena. Or now I get Marty Bird. You're always flipping the audience off, even in your character name. We're sneaky smart on that show. What? Can we speak to Marty Bird? Yeah. Sure.
Where, let me get, let me get the actor studio. Let me get, let me get Marty Bird here. Let me get, let me get, I'll get my, I'll get my, I'll get my, my dumb concerned face on. Yeah. Yeah. Don't you say that. It looks a lot like my smiling face. Oh no. Jason this morning went where he got sort of,
like, sort of madamee when we were in the hotel room. And then he said, do you know what your face is doing right now? Because they're looking at his face with this and he goes, am I smiling? No, you're doing the opposite of smiling. We have covered this on the shelf. Anybody is north of 40 in this audience.
Are you not surprised? I'm surprised. When I watch, you know, as you do, you watch a playback of stuff when you're shooting something and say, I know what I'm trying to do as an actor. I'm trying to have a certain, but this is so heavy now,
that I look concerned when I'm just supposed to be listening. And so to get, I think we talked about this on the podcast, when I want, I have to tell myself, when I want to just be level, I have to tell my face to be semi-surprised. Just a little bit, so now it's neutral. So semi-surprised is alright. And then if I wanted to seem happy, I have to think, ebulient. That's a long, yeah.
Because in the morning, I try to keep my distance from you because I'm like, is he pissed at me? Yeah, you're just like, that's my good morning. He's a little, he's a little bit grumpy. I'm a little bit grumpy. Yeah, I'm a grumpy. I'm a grumpy. little bit grumpy. Yeah, I'm a little grumpy. I'm a little grumpy. You're coughing and then you're good.
I am moody. All right. Man, we've covered a lot. We're not even supposed to be talking to you. We're supposed to be talking to ourselves. I know, I know, it's so crazy. It's a little nuts. It's a little surreal, but.
Is this just to just the lace? No, just a snap. The snap. The snap. I'm wearing my sport piece tonight. It snaps. But they come loose. I didn't realize it was going to be so windy. But the helmet you slept in shaped it nicely.
Yeah, it keeps it. Well, it holds it. Yeah. I'm not stupid, dude. These nice new clothes were wearing. I know. I'm not stupid, dude. In these nice new clothes we're wearing. I know. We wear this on the podcast. We look at jammers in the podcast.
Yeah. All right. Shall we? Oh, you want to get going? I'm sorry. Are you, uh, you ever heard out? What are you doing? No, I felt bad.
Did you guys enjoy the check-in? Showing your vaccination? It takes you long, right? Where's your hat? Where's my hat? with a check-in showing your backs in ASAP. It takes too long, right? Where's your hat, Sean? Where's my hat? I know. This is it. No, I thought I'd, I'd, I'd, not wear one.
You usually wear a, that's why I'm wearing a ballad question. They'll wear one. Otherwise, I tell, I look like a pet a file if I, I don't know. Can I watch your kids, you know? You know? So I just tried to, Can I watch your kids? You know? So I just tried it. It just takes a lot of...
You'll see. It takes too long to do something. So I got a lot of product in it. That's why I wear a hat. I'm like, I'm too exhausted and an old... Did, now, did Scotty, did Scotty tell you not to wear a hat on the tour? Yes, he did.
He did, right? I knew him. Yeah, he's like, you're not gonna go out there looking like an asshole, are you? Yeah. You thought it would take you about half a dude? Right. All right.
This is your guess, is it? Yeah, yeah. So, drink up. Oh, yeah. And by the way, just to remind people, we don't know who this is. We do. We do. We legitimately don't know who it is.
So we never do. And we never do, but we've carried this on. Actually, the exception is Kamala Harris and Stacey Abrams, we all knew about, because there was a lot of apparatus to organize that. Yeah. Yeah. But other than that, I think we've always not known. Not known.
And that is totally legit. But this took some doing because this person is backstage and they had to be in a certain area backstage. They had to be brought here from out of town and they had to. So it was a big deal to keep it from these guys. And we can. And some other people in the tour know who it is.
So we keep on having to say the special guest. Do you have questions on you? Do you have your intro memorized? I don't have my intro memorized. My intro's kind of winging it. If you could keep them out. I've got my cards. You can keep them out.
By the way, I don't want to hold them. I don't think you understand the concept of winging it. You can't look at fucking no. Those are my questions. Those are my questions, not my intro. OK. Here's something I've never admitted this to because you do your little intro sometimes, which are obviously written right before.
Yeah, right before. And I'm not sure. I know I spend time on mine. Here's an admission. I've never written one. That's clear. That's clear. Never what?
I've never written an intro. Oh. Really? No. Why? No. Why? Because we're going to get to them. Did you write one for this person? I did not.
No, this person doesn't need an intro. Oh. Oh, really? This person legitimately is someone who has worn many, many hats. Oh. This person has been... This person was a cop. Um...
不，这个人不需要介绍。噢。噢，真的吗？这个人真的是一个涉猎极广的人。噢。这个人曾经……这个人当过警察。嗯……
As a cop? America's mayor? This person was a cop. Is that his coming out? I would like that interview. Wouldn't that be fun? Turn up the heat and hear a little bit. Get some sweat going.
当过警察？美国市长？这个人当过警察。那是他的出柜吗？我挺想做那个采访的。那不是挺有意思的吗？加点热度，听听看。出点汗。
LAUGHTER Great. We got our first cut. Turn up the heat and hear a little bit get some sweat Great We got our we got our first cut. We got our first thing we have to cut. Why is that bad? That'd be a good interview. Do you so this person was a cop that this person has been a cop this person has been a race car driver This person I'm telling you this person went a lot of different cats. This person has been a figure skater. This person is America's best friend. This person has been a basketball player. This person has been and will always be to me the funniest guy that I know.
笑声 太棒了。我们完成了第一个剪辑。加点热度，听听看，出点汗，太棒了。我们有……我们有第一个剪辑。我们有第一个需要剪掉的部分。为什么这不好？那会是个不错的采访。所以这个人曾是个警察，这个人曾是个警察，这个人曾是个赛车手。我跟你说，这个人尝试过很多不同的身份。这个人曾是个花样滑冰运动员。这个人是美国最好的朋友。这个人曾是个篮球运动员。这个人过去是，对我而言也将永远是我认识的最好笑的家伙。
Mr. Will Fowl! Oh I'm so mad at you. Okay. I asked you, is there a dress code? You said... You said... It's formal. Tuxedos and cool sunglasses. I took them. You specifically said... That was when it was gonna be in Toronto. And I swear, I don't see mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I'm happy to do it. You guys didn't have to pay me the fee that you're paying me.
威尔·法瑞尔先生！噢，我太生你的气了。好吧。我问过你，有德雷斯科尔（着装规范）吗？你说……你说……是正式服装。要穿燕尾服，戴酷炫的太阳镜。我穿了。你特指……那是打算在多伦多举行的时候。我发誓，我看不懂，我是说，我是说，我是说……我很乐意这么做。你们根本不用付我那个出场费。
They don't know. They don't know. They don't know. Is that the same outfit you wore on the plane? This is so high. OK, you guys flew me first class accommodations. I was not allowed to bring a change of clothes, though. That was the stipulation.
他们不知道。他们不知道。他们不知道。你身上穿的是不是你在飞机上穿的那套？这太……好吧，你们让我坐了头等舱。不过规定是不允许我带换洗衣服的。这就是条件。
What do you mean? But yeah, remember when people used to dress up on a flight? Yeah. I would bring a change of clothes, no, that was the stipulation. We don't need it. But yeah, remember when people used to dress up on a flight? Yeah, my dad tells me, no one does it anymore. I'm trying to bring it back. My mom was a stewardess for flight attendant for Pan Am. Their outfits were incredible back in the day, right? With the bowler hats, right?
什么意思？不过说真的，还记得以前人们坐飞机都会盛装打扮吗？对。我会带换洗衣服，不，这就是条件。我们不需要。不过说真的，还记得以前人们坐飞机都会盛装打扮吗？对，我爸告诉我，现在没人这么做了。我正试图让它重回流行。我妈以前是泛美航空的空姐、乘务员。以前他们的制服太不可思议了，对吧？戴着圆顶硬礼帽，对吧？
And everyone had to wear a suit and tie in first class, I think, right? Yeah, and to be fair, just to catch that mistake you made. Um, Philbox, to underline it and highlight it. Oh, stewardess. Yes, at the time, she referred to... What I was gonna say was in your defense at the time, she referred to herself as a stewardess.
而且我记得在头等舱里，每个人都得穿西装打领带，对吧？对，说句公道话，为了指出你刚才犯的那个错误。嗯，菲尔盒（Philbox），我要在下面划线并着重强调一下。噢，空姐。是的，当时她指的是……我想说的是，为了替你辩护，当时她自己称呼自己为空姐。
Yeah. Well, that's what it was called back in the day before. But you used to call her a waitress. She used to call her a waitress. She used to call her a waitress. But why did they switch it? Guys, it's a- We know, I'm a tour.
对。好吧，以前就是这么叫的。但你以前管她叫女服务员。你以前管她叫女服务员。你以前管她叫女服务员。但他们为什么要改呢？各位，这……我们知道，我是个巡演……
I know. Let's not get to you for the last night. Or we have him colors. The pan-hem classic. Yeah. Blue and white, and a little bit of teal, right? Wasn't there a teal? And splash of gold.
我知道。咱们别扯到你昨晚的事上。或者我们有他的代表色。泛美航空的经典色。对。蓝色和白色，还有一点青色，对吧？是不是有青色？还有一抹金色。
This splash of gold. Right for the wings. Did you have the travel, the shoulder bag? The Pan Am shoulder bag, oh sure I did, at all the swag. And we used to be able to ride with mom for free if there's empty seats. And then I would help out mom serving dinners to people.
这一抹金色。就在翅膀图案那。你有那种旅行肩包吗？泛美航空的肩包，噢，我当然有，那可是全套装备。而且以前如果有空座的话，我们可以免费搭乘妈妈的航班。然后我还会帮妈妈给乘客端晚餐。
I'd walk or I'd walk on my life. No, you did it. I'd walk or I'd walk on my life. No, you did it. Are you being serious? No, you did it. On my life, yeah. I'd walk down with their tray and can see that. And every time I've had you work in, even on vacation.
我会走来走去，或者说我发誓我会……不，你真的干过。我会走来走去，或者说我发誓我会……不，你真的干过。你是认真的吗？不，你真的干过。我发誓，真的。我会拿着他们的餐盘走过去，看得出来。而且每次我都让你干活，甚至在度假的时候。
Oh, I'm sorry. I was on the nap. I'm sorry. Oh, you're evil. I flew all around the world, perfect. You were thrilled to do it. It's thrilled to do it. Now, we had to be in suit and tie, including my sister.
噢，对不起。我当时在睡午觉。对不起。噢，你太坏了。我环游了全世界，完美。你当时可乐意干了。乐意至极。当时，我们必须穿西装打领带，包括我妹妹在内。
No. But you had to be dressed suit and tie including my sister. No, but you had to be dressed up and you couldn't check a bag because we never knew if we could get on the plane or not because you could only get on the plane if there's empty seats. So you had to be carry on bags. Oh, sorry, man. So let's get back to Will. Okay. It's February. Sure. It's pretty much the start of the year, so I thought I'd read my New Year's resolution. We're going to double back to the Pan Am story, because he's got something he really did the audience a favor.
不对。但你必须穿西装打领带，包括我妹妹在内。不对，但你必须盛装打扮，而且你不能托运行李，因为我们永远不知道能不能顺利登机，只有在有空座的情况下才能登机。所以你只能带随身行李。噢，抱歉，伙计。那我们说回威尔。好的。现在是二月份。没错。差不多是一年的开始，所以我想读一下我的新年愿望。我们等会儿要绕回泛美航空的故事，因为他做了一件真正对听众很好的事。
Stop! Stop saying pun unintended. That's a good note. Because I love puns. Whenever I use it, I mean it. Okay. Otherwise you just wouldn't say it. Why?
停！别再说“双关语本意并非如此”（pun unintended）了。这个提示不错。因为我喜欢双关语。每当我用它的时候，我都是认真的。好吧。否则你根本就不会说。为什么？
You're not going to do it if you don't intend to make a pun. You say it's like sayingintended after murdering somebody I'm just He's trying to wiggle in a promotion for murder bill coming on They applauded pretty quick they're aware of it. They haven't seen it yet. They haven't seen it yet It's very good. That's kind of you to say I mean keep talking really commit That's very good. That's kind of you to say. I mean, keep talking about that. Really commit.
如果你不是故意开玩笑，你是不会这么说的。你说这话就像谋杀某人后说“本意并非如此”一样。我只是……他正试图在播客里塞进一个宣传，因为威尔要来了。他们鼓掌挺快的，他们已经意识到了。他们还没看过呢。他们还没看过呢。这非常棒。你这么说真好。我是说，继续说，真的全身心投入进去。这非常棒。你这么说真好。我是说，继续谈那个。真的全身心投入。
I really want to commit this year to referring to all money slash cash as cheese or cheddar. Sure. And fully commit to it. And fully commit, and $100 bills as blue cheese. Do you? So I'd like, yes, I'd like to, can I have a couple of those in blue cheese? At the ATM, you can request. Yeah, we're love for you to say your agent calls us, as well we've got an offer, and your only thing is,
我今年真的想全身心投入，把所有的钱斜杠现金都称为“奶酪”（cheese）或“切达干酪”（cheddar）。没错。并且完全投入进去。完全投入，把100美元的钞票叫做“蓝纹奶酪”。是吗？所以我愿意，是的，我愿意……我能用蓝纹奶酪换几张那种的吗？在自动取款机上，你可以申请。是的，如果你的经纪人打电话给我们，我们很乐意听到你这样说，我们有一个报价，而你唯一关心的是，
how much cheddar are they offering? Right. Next person that says to me age before beauty, I'm going to knock out. OK. You just don't like it? Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
他们提供多少切达干酪？对。下一个对我说“尊老爱幼”的人，我要把他打倒在地。好吧。你就是不喜欢这句？嗯哼。嗯哼。
Oh, why? OK. Can you just don't like it? Okay, say 2022 in the house as much as possible. Eat more vegetables. Sure. Well, that would make a lot of sense. That's a good one. Do you guys not look at him and just fall in love? I can't swear. I could just stare at it the funniest man in the world. Yeah. Absolutely. Please.
噢，为什么？好吧。你能尽量少说“2022年当道”吗？多吃蔬菜。当然。嗯，那很有道理。这个不错。你们看着他，难道不会直接坠入爱河吗？我不能发誓。我能一直盯着他看，世界上最好笑的男人。没错。绝对的。请吧。
No. All right. Drink at least 50 liters of water a day. 50 liters. That seems like a lie. Do something special for a random stranger every day. That's nice. That's nice. I got you picked by their coffee for them. You know, help someone cross the street and then ask a stranger to do something special for me. That's right. Stuart, just pick one.
不。好吧。一天至少喝50升水。50升。这听起来像是个谎言。每天为某个素不相识的陌生人做一件特别的事。那挺好的。那挺好的。我懂，替他们买杯咖啡。你知道的，扶某人过马路，然后要求一个陌生人为我做一件特别的事。没错。斯图尔特，随便挑一个。
This comes back to getting the face of flight attendants because I have rights, too. That, I think, has a head full of steam already. Just follow that trend. Yeah, I got it. Never buy a pack of cigarettes again. There's plenty of half smoke butts out there with at least two or three drags left on them.
这就说回空姐的事了，因为我也有权利。那个，我觉得已经气势汹汹了。就顺着这个趋势来吧。对，我懂了。再也不买一整包烟了。外面有的是抽了一半的烟头，上面至少还能吸两三口。
So you just gotta look on the ground. Don't shake your head at me. Wait, that might go double for cups of coffee. Right. I got a lot, by the way. I'm glad this list is so long. I mean, you should have said, well, you don't fall through, I don't know.
所以你只需要看着地面。别对我摇头。等等，咖啡杯可能也是这样。没错。顺便说一句，我有很多。我很高兴这个清单这么长。我的意思是，你本该说，好吧，你不会掉下去，我不知道。
This list is like even five more minutes long. It would have been nice if you started with buckle up. Tell my wife, I love her at least once a month. And then treat myself to a nice piece of jewelry. Remind myself daily that I'm afraid of no-gos. It's good. You're through. Can you forward these to me? I will. Really try to stop breeding exotic big cats. Mostly tigers and jaguars. Really pride. Mostly.
这个清单要是再长个五分钟就好了。你要是一开始就说“系好安全带”就好了。告诉我的妻子，我至少一个月爱她一次。然后奖励自己一件漂亮的珠宝。每天提醒自己我无所畏惧。这挺好的。你说完了。你能把这些转发给我吗？我会的。真的努力停止繁殖珍稀的大型猫科动物。主要是老虎和美洲虎。真的引以为傲。主要是。
Mostly. Put all my money, all of it. Every last penny. All the cheddar. In Bitcoin. Do not look back. Take down my Christmas tree. And we will be right back.
主要是。把我所有的钱，所有的。最后一分钱。所有的切达干酪。都投进比特币。绝不回头。拿下我的圣诞树。我们马上回来。
Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. Now, there are times when I'm feeling my feet firmly underneath me, and other times when I'm kind of wobbling around. You know, mentally speaking, if you know what I mean, Shiny, huh? And I like a little bit of help. And what's better than BetterHelp? D.C. Right. Okay, this is the thing. I mean, Shawnee, huh? And I like a little bit of help. And what's better than better help?
Smartless 播客由 BetterHelp 赞助。有时候，我觉得双脚稳稳地踩在地上，而有时我又感觉自己摇摇晃晃。你知道的，从精神层面上来说，如果你懂我的意思的话，闪闪发光，对吧？我喜欢寻求一点帮助。还有什么比 BetterHelp 更好呢？D.C. 没错。好吧，就是这样。我是说，闪闪发光，对吧？我喜欢寻求一点帮助。还有什么比 BetterHelp 更好呢？
D.C. Right? OK, this is the high level stuff. By the way, do you feel like you're a beautiful girl? I feel pretty good. Like today, I wouldn't bother the people at better help today. But it's nice to know that they're there when I do need it.
D.C. 对吧？好吧，这可是高水平的内容。顺便问一句，你觉得自己是个美丽的女孩吗？我感觉挺好的。就像今天，我今天不会去麻烦 BetterHelp 的人。但很高兴知道当我确实需要的时候他们就在那里。
I mean, sometimes in life we're faced with tough choices, Shawnee, and the path forward isn't always clear. Whether you're dealing with decisions around career, relationships, or anything else, therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life. So you can move forward with confidence and excitement, right, Sean? Trusting yourself to make decisions that align
我的意思是，有时在生活中我们会面临艰难的选择，肖恩，前进的道路并不总是清晰的。无论你是在处理关于职业、人际关系还是其他任何事情的决定，疗愈都能帮助你在探索生活时与你真正想要的东西保持联系。这样你就能充满自信和兴奋地前进，对吧，肖恩？相信自己能够做出符合
with your values is like anything. The more you practice it, the easier it gets. But seriously, folks, therapy has something that has really helped me through a lot of things in life, especially in the last 10 years of my life. So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge.
你价值观的决定就像做任何事情一样。你练习得越多，它就越容易。但说真的，各位，心理疗愈确实在生活的很多方面帮助过我，尤其是在我过去的10年里。所以，如果你正在考虑开始心理疗愈，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线上，旨在提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程的服务。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。
Let therapy be your map with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartness today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.hlp.com slash smartness. Looking for love? I'm Jujube and on this season of Queen of Hearts, we're going all the way down to sunny sexy Miami. I'm setting up the hottest singles in South Florida. Maybe I can find them their perfect partner or someone to fulfill their sexiest fantasies. A man who unconditionally loves me and is a raging feminist and then ties me up rubbing oils on me then surprise gets a girl to lick my foot
让心理疗愈成为你的地图，BetterHelp 为你指引。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartness，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.hlp.com/smartness。在寻找真爱吗？我是 Jujube，在这一季的《红心女王》中，我们将一路前往阳光性感迈阿密。我正在为南佛罗里达州最热门的单身男女牵线搭桥。也许我能为他们找到完美的伴侣，或者能满足他们最性感幻想的人。一个无条件爱我、是个狂热的女权主义者，然后把我绑起来，在我身上涂满精油，接着出人意料地让一个女孩舔我的脚，
and another guy to put it in my foot and has a huge... But remember there's a twist no one can see each other until the very end. Cameras on! Oh hi! Hi! Woo! Got me blessed! Follow Queen of Hearts on Amazon Music or wherever you get your podcasts.
让另一个家伙把脚放进去，而且还有一个巨大的……但记住，这里有一个反转，直到最后一刻谁也看不到谁。镜头开着！噢，嗨！嗨！呜！保佑我！在亚马逊音乐或你获取播客的任何地方关注《红心女王》。
You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music, included with Prime. Download the Amazon Music app now, or you can listen ad-free by subscribing to Wonder RePlus and Apple Podcasts or the Wonder App. Raising kids can be one of the greatest rewards of a parent's life. But come on, someday's parenting is unbearable. I love my kid, but is a new parenting podcast from Wondry that shares a refreshingly honest and insightful take on parenting. Hosted by myself, Megan Galey, Chris Garcia, and Kurt Brownleur, we will be your resident
你可以在亚马逊音乐上免广告收听，这是 Prime 会员权益的一部分。立即下载亚马逊音乐 App，或者订阅 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondry Plus 或 Wondry App 即可免广告收听。抚养孩子可能是父母一生中最大的回报之一。但说实话，有时养育孩子简直令人崩溃。我爱我的孩子，但……是 Wondry 推出的全新育儿播客，以令人耳目一新的坦诚和深刻视角分享育儿经。由我和梅根·盖利（Megan Galey）、克里斯·加西亚（Chris Garcia）以及库尔特·布劳恩奥勒（Kurt Braunohler）共同主持，我们将成为你们常驻的
not-so- so expert experts. Each week we'll share a parenting story that'll have you laughing, nodding, and thinking. Oh yeah, I have absolutely been there. We'll talk about what went right and wrong. What would we do differently? And the next time you step on yet another stray Lego in the middle of the night, you'll feel less alone. So if you like to laugh with us as we talk about the hardest job in the world, listen
算不上专家的专家。每周我们将分享一个育儿故事，让你开怀大笑、频频点头并心想：噢，是的，我绝对经历过。我们会聊聊什么做对了，什么做错了。我们会做哪些不同的尝试？当你在深夜又一次踩到一颗迷路的乐高积木时，你会觉得没那么孤单了。所以，如果你喜欢和我们一起笑着谈论这个世界上最困难的工作，那就去
to, I love my kid, but wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. And now back to the show. Avoid slipping into vocal fries so much. Right. Yeah. You guys know what that is. I just found out what that was about six months ago. You know, when you talk like that, I'm like, God.
收听《我爱我的孩子，但是……》，无论你在哪里获取播客都可以。你可以在亚马逊音乐或 Wondry App 上免广告收听。现在回到节目中。尽量少用声带颤音。对。没错。你们知道那是什么吗。我大概六个月前才知道那是什么。你知道的，当你那样说话时，我会想，天哪。
It's like Valley Girl's Peak, right? That's going back a bit. Every sentence ends in a question mark. No, it's talking like, you know, like that's... Isn't that vocal fry? I got one more example. I don't want to do it again. I did.
就像山谷女孩的巅峰时期，对吧？那有点久远了。每个句子都以问号结尾。不，那是在说话，你知道的，就像……那不就是声带颤音吗？我再举个例子。我不想再来一次了。我刚才做了。
All I see are two cameras over there, and I don't. I don't can't do it again. Thank God for the internet, huh? Because that will hide you for so long. By the way, Willing, again, this is starting to read like a manifesto, but go ahead. Chicago. Chicago PD.
我看到的只有那边两个摄像头，而我没有。我不能再来一次了。感谢互联网，对吧？因为那能把你隐藏很久。顺便说一句，威尔，再次提醒，这开始读起来像是一份宣言了，但你继续。芝加哥。芝加哥警署。
Chicago Fire. Chicago Mad. These are the three shows you're promising to watch this year? No, I just love them. You love them. Yeah. It's actually an ad. It's actually an advertisement. That's a paid ad.
芝加哥烈焰。芝加哥……这些就是你承诺今年要看的三个节目吗？不，我只是爱它们。你爱它们。对。其实这是一个广告。其实这是一个广告。这是一个付费广告。
It's a paid ad. That I snuck on with Smart List. What the fuck? What the fuck? Thank you guys. Speaking of Chicago, you look dangerously close to Harry Carey right now. Oh, did I?
这是一个付费广告。我偷偷塞进 Smart List 里的。搞什么鬼？搞什么鬼？谢谢你们，伙计们。说到芝加哥，你现在的样子危险地接近哈里·凯瑞（Harry Caray）。噢，是吗？
Yeah. Yeah. I'm trying to ag him on just a little. Chicago peed in! Oh! What I love is it has all the thrill and excitement of the inner workings of a police department. With all the backyard knowledge of Chicago. Wait, you know, I'm from Chicago and. What's more excited than solving a homicide at Rigley Field?
对。对。我只是稍微挑逗他一下。芝加哥警署！噢！我喜欢的是，它拥有警察局内部运作的所有惊险与刺激。还有芝加哥的各种街头智慧。等等，你知道的，我是芝加哥人，而且。还有什么比在瑞格利球场（Wrigley Field）破获谋杀案更令人兴奋的呢？
I'm sorry, I got a lot more. Should I stop it? No, listen, I mean. Our guest don't show a preparer. No, this is what a jack- I'm gonna speed through. I'll speed through. I don't really have questions.
不好意思，我还有很多要说的。我该停下来吗？不，听着，我是说。我们的嘉宾可没做准备。不，这家伙真是个……我要快点讲。我快点讲。我其实没什么问题。
Try the last questions. Try to work on my intense hatred of manatees. Yellowjackets streaming now on Showtime. Oh, Jesus, man. What is that? Suck an ass. Hollywood has got you in there. You don't know how much blue cheese I just landed right there.
试试最后几个问题。试着克服我对海牛的强烈憎恨。目前正在 Showtime 热播的《黄蜂》第四季。噢，天哪，伙计。那是什么？太烂了。好莱坞把你给套进去了。你都不知道我刚刚在那里弄到了多少蓝纹奶酪。
Well, not yet. Not yet, but when this airs. OK. All right. Finally, finally changed my name to DeBaby, It's not yet, but when this airs. Okay. Alright. Finally, finally changed my name to DeBaby, unless it's already taken. Or finally changed my name to Yay, unless that's already taken. No, you're good. They're both taken.
嗯，还没。还没有，但等这期播出的时候。好的。好吧。最后，终于把我的名字改成了 DeBaby，还没，但等这期播出的时候。好的。好吧。最后，终于把我的名字改成了 DeBaby，除非这个名字已经被用了。或者最后把我的名字改成了 Yay，除非那个已经被用了。不，你挺好的。这两个都被用了。
How do you spell it? Why? No, that's taken. What is it, yay or ye? Well, I thought, like, why, a-y isn't taken if you want that. I just want, why, I just want y-e. You can't have it. Taken?
你怎么拼？为什么？不，那个被用了。是 yay 还是 ye？嗯，我想，就像，如果你想要那个的话，why, a-y 没被用。我只想要，why，我只想要 y-e。你不能用。被用了？
Taken. I don't know. I mean, if you're pronouncing it like the way you're doing it, I think that you're good. I mean, I should preface it by saying, I'm not a lawyer. Wait, does Kanye want it pronounced yay or ye? Ye? Ye? Ye? You see, you're hearing Vogue.
被用了。我不知道。我的意思是，如果你发音的方式跟你刚才一样的话，我觉得你就没问题。我的意思是，我得先声明一下，我不是律师。等等，侃爷（Kanye）希望别人把他的名字读作 yay 还是 ye？Ye？Ye？Ye？你看，你听到的是 Vogue。
I just thought of a fourth one, Chicago Law. Oh, Chicago Law. You can play a lawyer. Shit. If, by the way, now, this is like a trademark thing. It's her name, Mike Davis. Sounds like Terry Seattle. He does, I like Terry Seattle.
我刚刚想到了第四个，芝加哥律所。噢，芝加哥律所。你可以演个律师。该死。顺便说一句，现在，这就像是个商标一样的事。那是她的名字，迈克·戴维斯（Mike Davis）。听起来像特里·西雅图（Terry Seattle）。他确实是，我喜欢特里·西雅图。
Terry Seattle. Remember to have like Terry Seattle. Remember to talk louder on my cell phone when I'm in public, especially on an airplane. Eat more roadkill. More. If we all ate roadkill, at least one mill a week, we'd reduce our carbon footprint by 25%. You almost couldn't get that one out. You like that one. Land voice over contract for Reese's peanut butter. What the fuck? And don't be sorry about it. Don't so worried about it. Good luck.
特里·西雅图。记得像特里·西雅图那样。记得在公共场所时手机声音放大一点，尤其是坐飞机的时候。多吃路杀动物。再多点。如果我们都吃路杀动物，一周至少吃一顿，我们的碳足迹就能减少25%。你差点没说出那句话。你挺喜欢那句的。拿下了里斯花生酱的配音合同。什么鬼？而且别为此感到抱歉。别那么担心。祝你好运。
Will, can you roll down your sock a little bit more? Sorry. Just get it all the way down. Come on. Jason and I got an argument for real just before the show because I did have a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup. Also paid ad ends. Jason said, in that way, he goes, oh, it's so funny. I said, how long you do, thank you Will.
威尔，你的袜子能往下拉一点点吗？抱歉。直接拉到底吧。拜托。我和杰森在演出前真的吵了一架，因为我确实吃了一个里斯花生酱杯。另外付费广告结束了。杰森当时说，用那种语气，他说，哦，太搞笑了。我说，你演了多久，谢谢你，威尔。
They're really funny, by the way. I actually stop it's so funny. I said, how long do you do? Thank you, Will. They're really funny, by the way. Thank you, man. I actually stop and watch them every time I see them. Thank you. It's so nice to get a compliment from a friend. Whoa. Fuck it.
顺便说一句，它们真的很好笑。我其实停下，太搞笑了。我说，你演了多久？谢谢你，威尔。顺便说一句，它们真的很好笑。谢谢你，伙计。每次看到它们，我其实都会停下来看。谢谢。能得到朋友的夸奖真是太好了。哇。去他的。
I mean, the last great commercial I saw was the Dodge thing that you did way back when. Remember that was for Dodge, wasn't it? Right, yeah. Have you done a commercial since then? I did one for GM. Oh, GMC. Not GMC, not GMC trucks.
我是说，我看到的最后一部伟大的商业广告是你很久以前拍的道奇的那个。记得那是为道奇拍的对吧？对，没错。从那以后你还拍过广告吗？我为通用拍过一个。哦，GMC。不是GMC，不是GMC卡车。
No, not GMC. So you did GMC, he does GM cars. That's the GMC, right? GMC is a truck, is a division of GM. What's GM? That's the big overall company. Yeah. General merchandise.
不，不是GMC。所以你拍的是GMC，他拍的是通用汽车。那是GMC，对吧？GMC是卡车，是通用汽车的一个部门。什么是通用汽车？那是总公司。对。通用百货。
I don't like me. I thought I would talk about light trucks. No, we talk. I mean we're talking about professional great vehicles And we've only been doing it for 23 years look here's the point Here's and we're not like a world record and vice-vers. I don't know It might be but I try not to someone Google it. I tried not to talk about it in front of people It might be, but I try not to... Someone Google it. I try not to talk about it in front of people.
我不喜欢我。我以为我会谈论轻型卡车。不，我们谈。我是说我们在谈论专业级车辆，而我们已经做了23年了。听着，重点是。重点是，我们不像什么世界纪录，反之亦然。我不知道。也许是吧，但我尽量不——有人去谷歌一下。我尽量不在别人面前谈论它。也许是吧，但我尽量不……有人去谷歌一下。我尽量不在别人面前谈论它。
In front of the theater of... Pax theater of people? No, because it's gross, but... Uh... But you love it. I love it. But you're a good match for it because you are kind of a professional grade kind of guy, right? It fits him.
在……帕克斯剧院的人群面前？不，因为这很恶心，但是……呃……但你很喜欢。我很喜欢。但你很适合这个，因为你算是一个专业级的那种人，对吧？这很适合他。
Thank you. Well, the voice alone is like a truck. It sounds like a truck. It's burned out. Who sings that song, believer? Don't stop believing? No, believer. Imagine dragging these nuts across your face. Is that on my list? See that, Borg. The last one is whatever dragon. Let's say that more. The last one is whatever dragon you're not. Which is not really a resolution, it's just a reminder to take chances. Uh-huh.
谢谢。嗯，光是这个声音就像一辆卡车。听起来像辆卡车。已经嗓子哑了。谁唱的那首歌，《信徒》？别停止相信？不，《信徒》。想象把这些蛋蛋在你的脸上拖来拖去。这在我的清单上吗？看到了吗，博格。最后一个是管他什么龙。多说几次这个。最后一个是管他什么龙你都不是。这其实不是一个决心，这只是一个抓住机会的提醒。呃-huh。
And be more spontaneous. Yeah, yeah. Even though it's on my list. Well, it makes me think, it's not finished. It's not done. OK, it's my last one. I don't know.
而且要更随性一点。对，对。尽管它在我的清单上。嗯，这让我想起，还没完成。还没做完。好吧，这是我的最后一个。我不知道。
Remove all and repeat all of my music from Spotify, all my albums. There we go. Oh, all my albums. All of them. All of them. You think cupcake party. Shhh.
从Spotify上删除并重复我的所有音乐，我所有的专辑。这就对了。哦，我所有的专辑。所有的。全都要。你觉得纸杯蛋糕派对。嘘。
All my back. Go revolution yesterday. Not on back. Go revolution yesterday. Not on there. Grandma's unicorn. Jesus clown. That's a B side. Even the B side. Get it on.
我所有的回归。昨天去革命。不在回归。昨天去革命。不在那上面。奶奶的独角兽。耶稣小丑。那是B面曲。连B面曲都要。开始吧。
And will why? Here we go. Here we go. Why are you talking about me? Because. Because it's a bad platform. Yeah, it's a bad. Yeah, yeah.
威尔，为什么？我们开始吧。我们开始吧。你为什么在说我？因为。因为这是个糟糕的平台。对，这是个糟糕的。对，对。
Because you have a lot of glitches. Yeah, a lot of glitches. Yeah, it's a bad. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because you have a lot of glitches. Yeah, a lot of glitches. And your music is pure. Is that it? We're getting there. We're halfway done. That was it.
因为你有很多故障。对，有很多故障。对，这是个糟糕的。对，对，对。因为你有很多故障。对，有很多故障。而你的音乐是纯粹的。就这样吗？我们快完成了。就是这样。
That was it. Yeah. Will Ferrell's New Year Resolution. But Will, so sitting here thinking and being- That's our time. Oh, wait, hang on, he's getting a call. He's taking a car you face Will I gotta say sitting here on the stage I was gonna say and doing that and and I was thinking and
就是这样。是的。威尔·法瑞尔的新年决心。但是威尔，所以坐在这里思考和——我们的时间到了。哦，等等，等一下，他有电话。你得吃车脸，威尔，我得说，坐在这里的舞台上，我本来想说，做那个，然后我一直在想……
With all these people with all these people here Do you miss and I know we've asked you this before but how much do you miss Performing every week like you did for a long time. You guys are front of an audience. Are you joining right now, Sean? Am I right? You were kind of yawning, weren't you? I started, I've been yawning for 20 minutes. Let's see.
在场的这么多人，在场的这么多人，你怀念——我知道我们以前问过你这个问题——你有多怀念像以前那样每周表演，就像你做了很久的那样？你们面对着观众。肖恩，你现在在加入吗？我说的对吗？你刚才有点打哈欠，对吧？我开始了，我已经打了20分钟哈欠了。我们看看。
LAUGHTER Sean, Jason forced Sean to walk a lot earlier today. You guys were on the birds all over the city. Yeah, I heard. Yeah, yeah. We did the birds, but it started as a walk, and then this is very exhausted. I, I'm not. You make me laugh harder than anybody.
笑声 肖恩，杰森今天早些时候强迫肖恩走了很多路。你们全城到处骑共享单车。对，我听说过。对，对。我们骑了单车，但开始是步行，然后这非常累人。我，我不是。你让我笑得比任何人都厉害。
I didn't even sleep last night, right? I didn't sleep. I got up at like three or four in the morning because these guys are like, they can do the switch from, I wasn't supposed to use ghost time. Like, it was problem. I need like two weeks, and I don't have it. Right. But it should be, two weeks and I don't have it. Right.
我昨晚甚至都没睡，对吧？我没睡。我大概三四点就醒了，因为这些家伙就像，他们可以切换，我本不该用幽灵时间的。就像，这是个问题。我需要大约两周时间，而我没有。对。但应该是，两周时间而我没有。对。
But it should be, you are a little bit tired. I'm okay. Why is everybody on my back about being tired? Because you were yawning when Will was doing. I was not yawning. I was like, this is my thing. I was like, okay. Good God.
但应该是，你确实有点累了。我没事。为什么每个人都盯着我累不累不放？因为威尔在表演时你在打哈欠。我才没有打哈欠。我当时是，这是我的风格。我当时是，好吧。天哪。
Do you know? Look at the foot. Maybe it's a different problem. Do you know what a yawning is? I'm pretty sure I can identify a yarn when I see it. You know, I did a small scene in a movie with Kevin Hart, and I was doing my... Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
你知道吗？看那只脚。也许是另一个问题。你知道什么是打哈欠吗？我挺确定我看到打哈欠时能认出来。你知道的，我在一部电影里和凯文·哈特拍过一个的小场面，我当时在做我的……对，谢谢。谢谢。
And we're doing my single, right? So the camera's on me, and the person that you're talking to is behind the camera. Right here. So, okay, right. So then, so Kevin Hart's face is right here, and I'm talking to him. We're in the middle seat. The Hollywood bounce guard.
我们在做我的单口，对吧？所以摄像机对着我，而你说话的对象在摄像机后面。就在这儿。所以，好吧，对。所以，然后，凯文·哈特的脸就在这儿，我在跟他说话。我们坐在中间座位上。好莱坞保镖。
Falls asleep. He fell asleep while he's off camera. Camer's rolling. Who K-Hurt? Kevin Hart fell asleep while I'm doing my single. Wow. I'm talking literally his eyes close, and I thought, well, my only somebody has the guts.
睡着了。他在镜头外睡着了。摄像机还在拍。谁？K-Hurt？凯文·哈特在我说单口时睡着了。哇。我说话时他 literalmente 闭上了眼睛，我想，好吧，只有某人有这胆子。
And then... While you're performing to do it. K-Hurt, been a guest? No. That'd be a good one. Yeah. You guys could break that down. I'd like to talk to him about that.
然后……在你表演的时候干这个。K-Hurt，当过嘉宾吗？没有。那会是个不错的嘉宾。对。你们可以剖析一下。我很想跟他聊聊这个。
Yeah. Let's call him. Is that phone still in there? No, wait, I want to go. I want to to talk to him about that. Yeah. Let's call him. Is that phone still? I want to go back to this thing. Do you have a problem like I do with the changing because you travel a lot too and you that's the thing I don't understand about you guys who do like movie after movie after movie after movie is like how do you adjust and then have the energy after 14 hours to just get up and go like be fun ambient coke. Yep. Okay. Those are the two that looks in the old dot kit.
对。我们给他打电话。那个电话还在里面吗？不，等等，我想去。我想跟他聊聊这个。对。我们给他打电话。那个电话还在……我想回到这件事上。你和我一样对倒时差有意见吗，因为你也经常旅行，我不理解你们这些拍了一部又一部又一部电影的人的一点是，你们是怎么适应的，然后在14小时后怎么还能有精力直接起来去，就像变得很有趣、很嗨。没错。好吧。这俩是旧洗漱包里的。
Yeah. That's what he taught me. He told me you're going. I got two dot kits. One's brimming. You've been blowing about that. It spills out. Everytime. You're really open about your cocaine use, right? You have been for-wind about that. It spills out.
对。这就是他教我的。他告诉我你要走了。我有两个洗漱包。一个满满当当的。你一直在吹嘘那个。都溢出来了。每次都是。你对自己的可卡因使用一直很坦诚，对吧？你一直在这方面唠叨。都溢出来了。
You're really open about your cocaine use, right? You have been for a long time. I've never hidden that from anyone, not a soul. Yeah. The kids, you know what backstage, it's true story also, that we were trying to figure out Jason was, what is a dop kit? What does that mean?
你对自己的可卡因使用一直很坦诚，对吧？你这么做很久了。我从来没对任何人隐瞒过，连一个灵魂都没有。对。孩子们，你知道吗，在后台，这也是个真实的故事，我们当时在试图弄明白，杰森在想，什么是dop kit？那是什么意思？
We looked it up. Do you know why it's called the dop kit? Does anybody here know? Why? Why they call it dop. You know what a dop kit is? Do you know what it's called? It's called the Dopp Kid. Does anybody here know? Why? Why they call it Dopp? You know what a Dopp Kid is? Do you know what I'm saying? It's gotta be.
我们查过了。你知道它为什么叫dop kit吗？在座的有人知道吗？为什么？为什么他们叫dop。你知道什么是dop kit吗？你知道它为什么叫这个吗？它叫Dopp Kit。在座的有人知道吗？为什么？为什么他们叫Dopp？你知道什么是Dopp Kit吗？你知道我在说什么吗？肯定是的。
Some people refer to it as a toiletry bag or a shaving kit. Dopp Kid. It was anybody? Germany, yeah. Yeah. And what about it? This is all a boy we're trying to root out the Germans.
有些人称之为洗漱包或剃须包。Dopp Kit。有人知道吗？德国，对。对。那又怎样？这全是一个男孩，我们正试图把德国人找出来。
He's right there! Get him! We're right there! Get him! Get him! Get him! Now it's Dopp Kid! We got there! It! Now it's... Dupcic! That's the same word! His son is pounding him right now.
他就在那儿！抓住他！我们就在那儿！抓住他！抓住他！抓住他！现在是Dopp Kit！我们找到了！它！现在是……Dupcic！那是同一个词！他儿子现在正在捶他呢。
Do you see? No, it was a guy who was a leather smith in Germany and he came up with a toilet bag and to begin the Dupcic. Was his last name Dopp? Doppelt. Does that sound right to you, sir? Yeah. Well, of course it does.
看到了吗？不，在德国有个皮革匠，他设计了洗漱包，然后开始叫Dupcic。他姓Dopp吗？Doppelt。听起来对吗，先生？对。嗯，当然对了。
The German. I wanted to ask you this before. Who is your favorite, historically SNL performer? No, historically. Like, so you can go like before you, like when you were a kid that you watched and you were like, I love what that person does. Other than Gilda. Other than Gilda and Jim Balushi. Or John. Or John. No. Eddie Murphy pretty, pretty, pretty fun to be. I feel like it all kind of happened in various increments.
德国人。我之前就想问你这个。历史上你最喜欢的SNL演员是谁？不，历史上。我是说，你可以选在你之前，比如你小时候看过的，然后你觉得，我太喜欢那个人演的了。除了吉尔达。除了吉尔达和吉姆·贝鲁西。或者约翰。或者约翰。不。埃迪·墨菲挺、挺、挺有意思的。我觉得这一切都是分阶段发生的。
Right. For me, it was Dan Accurate, the first time I started. Yeah. Because I just thought, oh, that guy, who's this other guy? What? Dan Accurate. No, I thought you said somebody else. What do you see?
对。对我来说，我刚开始看时是丹·阿克罗伊德。对。因为我当时想，哦，那个家伙，这又是谁？什么？丹·阿克罗伊德。不，我以为你说了别人。你看到了什么？
I thought you said a second person. No, I'm your friend, not your dad. You have, this is about to. I was about to. But you have a beef with Sean, a little bit. You have been fighting for years. Tell them, tell them about your fight. Don't maybe pull up the emails.
我以为你说了第二个人。不，我是你朋友，不是你爸。你，这就要。我正准备。但你对肖恩有点意见。你们已经吵了好几年了。告诉他们，告诉他们你们的争执。别，也许别把邮件翻出来。
I mean, they're scathing. I am. I emailed Will today and I said, Sean hosted once. Yeah. And we just got off on the wrong. LAUGHTER He just came in all sassy and... I think we talked about this on the podcast maybe before.
我是说，那些邮件太尖刻了。我是。我今天给威尔发邮件说，肖恩主持过一次。对。然后我们一开始就合不来。笑声 他一进来就趾高气扬的……我想我们以前在播客里可能讨论过这个。
So forgive me, but one of the hardest times I ever laughed in my entire life was when we hosted and you came out and you didn't tell us in a schedule for me and you and Jimmy Fallon that you came out with a little tiny phone. Yeah. Yeah, Jeffree's. Jeffree. Jeffree's. God, that was so funny. Yeah. Jeffries. Jeffries.
所以请原谅我，我这辈子笑得最厉害的一次是在我们主持的时候，你走出来，却没有把行程告诉我和你还有吉米·法伦，你手里拿着一个超级小的手机出来。对。对，杰弗里斯。杰弗里斯。杰弗里斯。天哪，太搞笑了。对。杰弗里斯。杰弗里斯。
Jeffries. Jeffries. God, that was so funny. Yeah. And what was the other thing you did? Oh, and you came out on a scooter, which you didn't do in rehearsal. So you did not have the numbers?
杰弗里斯。杰弗里斯。天哪，太搞笑了。对。你还干了什么？哦，你骑着滑板车出来，彩排时你可没这么干。所以你没有排练过？
No, it was like, actually. It was a little jazzy. Yeah, the electric, oh my God, it was so funny. But so. There was no reason. Well, so funny. Dan Ackroyd. Yes. Eddie Murphy. Yeah, and Phil Harman.
不，就像，其实。是个小代步车。对，电动的，天哪，太搞笑了。但是所以。根本没必要。嗯，太搞笑了。丹·阿克罗伊德。是的。埃迪·墨菲。对，还有菲尔·哈特曼。
Yeah, Phil Harman. The great, so great Phil Harman. Don't worry, let's not forget about Bill Murray. But you know what he is, probably you say Phil. You just sparrage any of the customers. But those guys. Let's do that too. Yeah.
对，菲尔·哈特曼。伟大的、如此伟大的菲尔·哈特曼。别担心，我们别忘了比尔·默瑞。但你知道他是谁，也许你说是菲尔。你只是在贬低任何顾客。但那些家伙。我们也这样做。对。
Okay, so these are the ones I hate. Yeah, she's in my bottom three. Okay, bottom three. Yeah. You guys, you go first. I don't know why you're so on top. I don't know why you're the mom. Wait, do you like, you know what's so funny about, because, you know,
好吧，这些是我讨厌的。对，她在我的倒数前三里。好吧，倒数前三。对。你们，你们先来。我不知道为什么你这么靠前。我不知道为什么你是妈妈。等等，你觉得，你知道什么很有趣吗，因为，你知道，
it's kind of like when you have a teacher in school and you see them out of the grocery store, and you're like, oh my god, it's so bizarre. It's like, I didn't see you as a real person. I didn't see you as doing anything else than teaching in that room. And so for me, I always see, you've done so many movies and I've been so successful and everything you do, every appearance you do, you're always so unbelievably funny.
这就像你在学校里有个老师，你在杂货店偶遇他们，然后你会想，哦天哪，太诡异了。就像，我没把你看作一个真正的人。我只觉得你除了在那间教室里教书什么也没做。所以对我来说，我总是看到，你拍了那么多电影，而且获得了巨大的成功，你所做的每一件事，你的每一次公开露面，你总是那么不可思议地好笑。
I always picture like, what does he do on a day? What are you doing now other than doing this? Like, what do you do when you're not moving? It's terribly boring. Yeah. It's very, what does a boring day look like in your life? OK. Take one of my children to school.
我总是想象，他平常的一天都在干什么？除了做这个，你现在在干什么？比如，你不拍戏的时候都在干什么？无聊透顶。对。这非常，你生活中的无聊一天是什么样的？好吧。送我的一个孩子去上学。
Just the one. The other one is learning at home. They don't deserve to learn. They don't deserve me. We draw straws at the beginning of the school year. Yeah, what's called the private school tuition bucket. And we only got enough money for one kid. By the way, he has stallions, by the way.
就一个。另一个在家学习。他们不配学习。他们不配拥有我。我们在学年开始时抽签。对，所谓的私立学校学费桶。我们只有够一个孩子的钱。顺便说一句，他有种马，顺便说一句。
Our kids go to school somewhere near one another and everyone's in love with his kids. Like, these are these are models. One of my boys maybe sort of knows your daughter. Hey man. Through friends. So you see where I'm going with this? Yeah.
我们的孩子在离得不远的地方上学，每个人都迷恋他的孩子。就像，这些都是模特。我的一个儿子可能勉强认识你女儿。嘿，伙计。通过朋友。所以你明白我的意思了吗？对。
My daughter's bedroom walls are filled with the young feral. No, I'm kidding. But yeah, no, they nice nice gene pool there. Thank you. So boring day because I have a feeling. Not so much my work. I have a feeling it is similar to my boring day, probably close to your boring day too,
我女儿的卧室墙上贴满了年轻法瑞尔的照片。不，开玩笑的。但是，基因池确实很不错。谢谢。所以无聊的一天，因为我有种感觉。比起我的工作。我有种感觉，这和我的无聊一天很像，可能也接近你的无聊一天，
and yours as well. Try to exercise a little. A little drop off, little exercise, work in some lunch. What's your lunch look like? No, but I mean like it. What's your way? And you know about his unhealthy relationship with food. Go ahead.
还有你的。稍微锻炼一下。接送一下，稍微锻炼一下，顺便吃个午饭。你的午餐是什么样的？不，我是说。你的方式是什么？你知道他对食物不健康的饮食习惯。说吧。
No, but I bet he, I think you are a healthy eater. I don't know what I'm basing that on. I mean, sort of. Yeah. I think you're basing it on the nice fit of the suit. Well, I used to see, but I also used to see Will out jogging. We used to be a similar jogging loop.
不，但我敢打赌他，我觉得你是个健康饮食者。我不知道我是基于什么这么想的。我是说，算是吧。对。我觉得你是基于这套西装挺合身的。嗯，我以前见过，但我以前也见过威尔慢跑。我们以前在差不多的慢跑路线上。
So you like, you enjoy a healthy body. So you putting good fuel in that body? A lot of laughter during a healthy body there. By the way, can I thank him for all of us that he's so willing and generous to show his body in almost everything he does? Yes. I mean, the crumb cake hairdo on the chest is just... That's a lot.
所以你喜欢，你享受健康的身体。所以你在给那具身体注入好的燃料？在健康的身体里有大量的笑声。顺便说一句，我能代表我们所有人感谢他，感谢他如此乐意且慷慨地在他所做的几乎所有事情中展示自己的身体吗？是的。我是说，胸前那个酥皮蛋糕的发型简直……这太夸张了。
That's two and a half hours of makeup. Oh, I am. So good. I'm like a candle. You look at me. I am just... Shades down the channels, whimmer. Yeah, channel, exactly.
那是两个半小时的妆。哦，我是。太棒了。我就像一支蜡烛。你看着我。我只是……香奈儿走秀款，微光。对，香奈儿，没错。
That's just a chest and belly plate you put on. I remember sitting at a screening preview of some movie where I was shirtless, literally behind an audience member who went, oh boy. Oh, here we go again. Here we go again. It's so good. That and the other, remember, going to Sneaking
那只是你贴上去的胸部和腹部道具片。我还记得坐在某部我光着身子的电影的试映会上， literalmente 坐在一个观众身后，那个人说，哦，天哪。哦，又来了。又来了。太棒了。还有那个，还记得，偷偷溜进
into a movie to see it on opening weekend when they're used to opening weekends. And listening to one kid go, he's got a lazy eye. Look at him, he's got a lazy eye. I'm sitting right behind you. I sat right behind... He's got a lazy eye. Do I have a lazy eyes? I sat right behind Ron Howard in this wonderful film that he directed at a screening for like 12 people, it was the first time a screening.
电影院在首映周末去看电影，当他们习惯了首映周末时。然后听到一个小孩说，他有斜视。看他，他有斜视。我就坐在你身后。我坐在……他有斜视。我有斜视吗？我在这部他导演的精彩电影的试映会上坐在朗·霍华德身后，大约有12个人，那是第一次试映。
And right when it was done, he turned around and I go and he goes, oh, hey Sean, I go, hey, is the picture locked? I have a lot of thoughts. Did he go, or he was like, you're not wiping me in? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, I mean, it was his face. I was sitting next to somebody in a movie theater, packed a movie theater for a very, very good movie.
刚一放完，他转过身来，我说，他接着说，哦，嘿，肖恩，我说，嘿，画面定格了吗？我有很多想法。他有没有说，或者他是说，你不是在擦掉我？对，对，对。对，我是说，那是他的脸。我当时坐在电影院里某个人的旁边，一个爆满的电影院，看一部非常非常好的电影。
You all sold out, it was one empty seat in the house. And I'm sitting in a back row sitting next to somebody. And they don't, we don't, we haven't looked at each other. They don't know why I am. And a trailer comes on for a comedy that I, a trailer was not that great, not one laugh through the whole trailer, trailer ends. And then there's the silence as it goes black, and then another trailer's about it.
你们的票全卖光了，全场连一个空座都没有。我坐在后排，旁边坐着一个人。我们俩没有对视过。他不知道我是谁。接着播放了一部喜剧的预告片，那个预告片不是很好，整部预告片下来连一个笑声都没有，预告片结束了。然后是一片黑暗中的安静，接着又是另一个预告片。
But during that science, this guy thought he'd be funny and he said, no thanks. And then, it echoed. And I was, I was sitting there, I'm thinking, well, that was pretty good, but wouldn't it be better if I just tapped him right now? Yeah. Because like, I think my face was like the last face
但在那段安静中，这家伙觉得他自己很搞笑，他说了一句：“不用了，谢谢。”然后，声音有了回音。我当时坐在那儿心想，这挺不错的，不过要是我现在就拍他一下，会不会更好？对啊。因为我觉得我的脸就像是最后一张脸
on the trail, like, he's gonna know, he's gonna recognize. And I did. You did. Who did it? I tapped him on the shoulder. No, first I squared up to him, so I knew as soon as he turned to be looking at that, that tattoo he looked at,
在预告片里出现的那种，就像，他会知道，他会认出来的。我真的这么做了。你做了。谁做的？我拍了拍他的肩膀。不，首先我冲着他摆出对抗的架势，所以我知道只要他一转头就能看到那个，他看到的那个纹身，
I go, not for you. But then we were buddies, and we were laughing the whole way through the next one. Nobody delivers that shitiness better than you. I swear to guys, the fuck, you're best. It's so funny. But he killed it, and he got a huge laugh with the note, thanks. But if you ever had he got a huge laugh with the note, thanks.
我说：“不适合你。”但随后我们成了哥们儿，接下来的整个过程中我们一直在笑。没有人能比你把那种烂片感觉演得更到位了。我发誓，哥们儿，真他妈的，你是最棒的。太搞笑了。但他表现得很棒，凭借那句“谢谢”赢得了巨大的笑声。不过如果你曾经有过——他凭借那句“谢谢”赢得了巨大的笑声。
But if you ever had those, you ever have those people. Have you had at a premiere of something? Yeah. People come up, this happened to me. Parents of someone who worked on the film, dad grabs them by their shoulders, like, I don't care what they say, I loved it. Yeah.
但如果你曾经遇到过那种人，你有没有在某个首映式上遇到过？有。有人走过来，这事就发生在我身上。某个参演电影的工作人员的父母，爸爸一把抓住他们的肩膀，就像是，我才不管别人怎么说，我爱死这部电影了。对啊。
I was gonna say. Oh, what did they say? They were saying, they were already saying it? Yeah. I was gonna say, oh, what did they say? What did they say? They were already saying it? Yeah, it's not even in the theories. I've had friends, like specifically, like friends that you grow up with, and then you go back to your home telling, go back to your owner.
我正想说。哦，他们说什么了？他们当时就在说了？对。我本来想说，哦，他们说什么了？他们说什么了？他们当时就在说了？对，这甚至都不在剧本里。我有过这样的朋友，特别是那种一起长大的朋友，然后你回到你的家乡，回到你生养的地方。
I had a few friends go like, got that last one, huh? Not very good. As if like, hey, we're inside, and I can say to you that what you do for a living sucked And you're like yeah, I guess I mean I we haven't agreed on it, but I guess now we have so I I had this friend come back after a show I did the promises promises I'm Broadway and Everyone up. Rob is his drum. Rob is his drum. Rob is his drum. Rob is his drum. Take a bow, Sean. Take a bow.
我有几个朋友会说：“看了最后那个，是吧？不太好。”就好像，嘿，我们是自己人，我可以对你说你谋生的手段烂透了，而你会说，是的，我想是吧，虽然我们没达成一致，但我想现在我们有了。所以我当时有个朋友在我演出结束后回来，我演的是百老汇的《承诺，承诺》，每个人都起立。罗布是他的鼓。罗布是他的鼓。罗布是他的鼓。罗布是他的鼓。谢幕吧，肖恩。谢幕吧。
Take a bow. Okay. So, do one. Do one. Do one. Do one. Do one. Do one song from it.
谢幕吧。好吧。来一个。来一个。来一个。来一个。来一个。来一个其中的歌。
I have a little bit. No, and this person came up. I didn't know this person very well, and they said, one sees such a performance, and one can only say, Sean Hayes. You're so... Yeah, that's sort of a bittersweet. Yeah, I love those. It hurts.
我有一点。不，这个人走过来了。我跟这个人不是很熟，他说：“一个人看到这样的表演，只能说一句，肖恩·海斯。你太……”对，那种感觉有点苦乐参半。对，我喜欢那种。挺伤人的。
No, it's not so bad, that's fine. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Now, Will, what's being a back thing? What? What do you say we all do a cold reading of a scene from the OC? LAUGHTER Sean, you'll play Luke.
不，没那么糟糕，没关系。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。现在，威尔，做个背景设定是什么意思？什么？大家觉得我们来个《橘子郡男孩》某一幕的初读怎么样？笑声 肖恩，你演卢克。
I thought you were going to be... Sean, you're playing Luke. Uh, Jason, you will be Seth. Okay. You're going to be Seth. You're gonna be Seth. We're all playing. And they're all highlighted. Each of our lines are highlighted.
我以为你要去……肖恩，你演卢克。呃，杰森，你演赛斯。好吧。你要演赛斯。你要演赛斯。我们全都在演。而且它们都被高亮标记了。我们的每句台词都有高亮标注。
You're gonna play the part. You're playing Marissa. None of this is prepared. I'm Marissa. I'm Marissa. For you. I'm Ryan. Ryan.
你要演那个角色。你演玛丽莎。这些全都没有准备。我是玛丽莎。我是玛丽莎。给你。我是瑞恩。瑞恩。
Yes. For you. I have to say, by the way, yes, what Jason just said, you were fucking crazy. Like, this is, I just thought of this today. Am I? But can we just say, can we just say thank you? Yeah.
好的。给你。我不得不说，顺便说一句，对，刚才杰森说的，你他妈的太疯狂了。就像，这个，我今天才刚想到这个。是吗？不过我们能说，我们能说声谢谢吗？对。
Nobody, nobody ever comes on prepared. This is incredible. He's got, he's got, he's got index cards. He hasn't even gotten to it yet. I'm trying to make you guys laugh. Hey, I'm playing Marissa. Okay. So you don't have to thank him, but we're good.
从来没有人，从来没有人带着准备来。这太不可思议了。他有，他有，他有索引卡。他甚至还没用到呢。我是在逗你们笑。嘿，我在演玛丽莎。好吧。所以你们不用谢他，不过我们很好。
Everyone, this obviously is a cold dream. So everyone's familiar with the show OC, the great OC. Great OC. Okay. What was the song, the OC, anybody? Oh, thank you. California, here we come. And in the band.
各位，这显然是一次初读。所以大家都对《橘子郡男孩》这部剧很熟悉，伟大的《橘子郡男孩》。伟大的《橘子郡男孩》。好吧。那首歌是什么，《橘子郡男孩》的主题曲，有人知道吗？哦，谢谢。加州，我们来了。乐队唱起来。
California. California here we come and in the band California I'm saying for real will sing for real. I would but I can't remember that one All right, let's let's get today You got a you got a fucking dinner day It is unbelievable how would we rush here? Okay? We it would be. Okay, we are interior diner, day. Yeah. In a casual little restaurant by the water, Seth, Ryan, and Marissa eat a meal.
加州。加州我们来了，乐队唱起来。加州，我说真的，会认真唱的。我会的，但我记不得那首了。好了，让我们开始今天的内容。你今天有个他妈的晚餐戏 真是难以置信，我们怎么这么赶？好吧？我们，会是的。好吧，我们这是内景，餐馆，日。对。在水边的一家休闲小餐厅里，赛斯、瑞恩和玛丽莎在吃饭。
Okay? That's your setup. Here comes a dialogue. See, guys, I've been thinking about a plan. You know, right now, this could very well be the first stop on our pancake tour of America. Hey, like on the road. Like a woman, your marissa. Marissa. I got this you guys. That's offensive.
好吗？这就是你们的设定。台词来了。听着，伙计们，我一直在考虑一个计划。你知道，现在这很可能是我们美国煎饼之旅的第一站。嘿，就像在路上一样。就像个女人，你是玛丽莎。玛丽莎。这个我来应付，伙计们。这冒犯到我了。
Yeah. Right. Is it offensive because you think you sound plenty like a girl? First of all, first of all, I'm not auditioning for you. Hey, like on the road. There you go. That's my favorite book. Mine too. So here's the deal. Yep.
对。没错。是因为你觉得自己听起来很像个女孩，所以才觉得被冒犯了吗？首先，首先，我不是在为你试镜。嘿，就像在路上一样。给你。那是我的最爱。我也是。所以情况是这样的。没错。
My mom had this boyfriend. He hired me to work construction last summer. But then they broke up. He moved away to Austin. In Texas? He said if I was ever out there to look him up. Well, I mean, well, that's really kind of far. We were thinking like, come at Long Beach or something so we could all hang out.
我妈妈有个男朋友。去年夏天他雇我去做建筑工作。但后来他们分手了。他搬到了奥斯汀。在德克萨斯州？他说如果我什么时候去那边的话就去找他。嗯，我的意思是，嗯，那真的有点远。我们本来想的是，比如去长滩或者什么地方，这样我们大家就能一起玩了。
I'll need to get a couple of days work so I can get a little bit of travel money. Well, I mean, we can get you money. Ryan looks away, uncomfortable. Marissa and Seth seem to get the point. Well, I mean, you know, I guess in a way you're kind of lucky. One looks away, uncomfortable. Marissa and Seth seem to get the point. Well, I mean, you know, I guess in a way you're kind of lucky. You get to move to a whole new place.
我需要干几天活，这样我能攒点路费。嗯，我的意思是，我们可以给你弄到钱。瑞恩把视线移开，显得很不自在。玛丽莎和赛斯似乎明白了意思。嗯，我的意思是，你知道的，我想某种程度上你还挺幸运的。瑞恩把视线移开，显得很不自在。玛丽莎和赛斯似乎明白了意思。嗯，我的意思是，你知道的，我想某种程度上你还挺幸运的。你要搬到一个全新地方去。
Start over. Be whoever you want to be. That's really not so bad. Luke, Luke and a couple other guys walk in, banging on the door, banging the door on purpose and being rude and noisy in general. Hey, Puts. What's it take to get a menu around you?
重新开始。想成为谁就成为谁。其实也没那么糟。卢克，卢克和另外几个家伙走了进来，踢打着门，故意用力关门，表现得很粗鲁，而且吵吵闹闹的。嘿，小不点。在这儿点个菜单要费多大劲？
That's great. That's great. Yeah. That's great. Okay, I'll handle it. And it does say Marissa stands up. Oh, thank you. That's all right. That's all right. I'll handle it. And ruin your popularity, you know what?
太棒了。太棒了。对。太棒了。好吧，我来处理。上面确实写着玛丽莎站起来。哦，谢谢。没关系。没关系。我来处理。然后毁了你的名声，你知道吗？
Why don't you guys just sneak out back? Marissa gets up and heads for Luke's table. LAUGHTER And ruin your popularity. What's going on with you, too? Hey! Oh, sorry, Marissa. Kisses Luke on the cheek and then takes a seat with him. CHEERING And then takes a seat with him.
你们为什么不从后门溜出去呢？玛丽莎起身朝卢克的桌子走去。笑声 你们怎么也毁了名声。你们两个怎么回事？嘿！哦，对不起，玛丽莎。吻了卢克的脸颊，然后在他的座位上坐了下来。欢呼声 然后在他的座位上坐了下来。
And then takes a seat with him. And then takes a seat with him. Oh, and then takes a seat with him. Here we go. Thank you. I mean, you want the job or not? Okay, ready. Luke says...
然后在他的座位上坐了下来。然后在他的座位上坐了下来。哦，然后在他的座位上坐了下来。我们开始吧。谢谢。我的意思是，你到底要不要这份工作？好了，准备。卢克说……
How is the manicure? Oh, it was great. Well, Marissa distracts Ryan and Seth quickly leave their booth and head for a hallway toward a back exit. Marissa notices Seth and Ryan walking through and keeps talking, distracting Luke and the guys. So, what did you guys do today? Seth and Ryan try to hurry up, but Luke notices them. Hi, guys. How are you guys doing?
美甲做得怎么样？哦，太棒了。好吧，趁玛丽莎转移注意力，瑞恩和赛斯迅速离开他们的卡座，朝通往后门走廊的方向走去。玛丽莎注意到赛斯和瑞恩走过去，继续说话，以此分散卢克和那些家伙的注意力。那么，你们今天都干了什么？赛斯和瑞恩试图加快脚步，但卢克注意到了他们。嗨，伙计们。你们过得怎么样？
You like the food here too? Pretty awesome. Here comes, say it, Sean. Shut up. Okay. Seth says, well at least I don't shave my chest. Nice. Luke gets up. Oh God. What'd you say?
你也喜欢这里的食物？太棒了。来了，说吧，肖恩。闭嘴。好吧。赛斯说，好歹我不会刮胸毛。不错。卢克站起来。天哪。你刚才说什么？
Luke, come on. I was just saying you look nice in a sweater vest. It was a compliment. Luke gets up and sets face. Alright, bring it. We got it on its feet real quick, by the way. We're just workshopping this. You want me to break you, Cohen?
卢克，拜托。我只是说你穿毛衣背心很好看。那是个赞美。卢克站起来，摆好架势。好吧，来吧。顺便说一句，我们很快就把这个排练起来了。我们只是在即兴创作。你想让我打垮你吗，科恩？
Hey! How did I miss this episode? This show seems great. Just six pages left, guys. We're almost there. You guys have been so patient. Thank you. Hey, so then Luke says, no way, look who's back. Here he comes.
嘿！我怎么错过这一集了？这个节目看起来太棒了。伙计们，只剩六页了。我们快完成了。大家一直这么有耐心。谢谢。嘿，然后卢克说，没门，看看谁回来了。他来了。
Oh, wait. Cute Luke. Oh, I got it. God damn it. No way. Cute, Louie. Oh, I got it. God damn it. No way. Look who's back. You know, you're a little far from eight mile. Louie, don't.
哦，等等。可爱的卢克。哦，我明白了。该死。没门。可爱的路易。哦，我明白了。该死。没门。看看谁回来了。你知道的，你离八英里路（8 Mile）有点远。路易，别这样。
What did you, like, spokesperson for Geeks of America or something? Nice. That's a sick bird. They all laugh. They all laugh. Oh, Ryan laughs. Here comes big finish. You know what I like about rich kids?
你是什么，比如美国极客协会的发言人还是什么的？不错。那是一只很酷的鸟。他们都笑了。他们都笑了。哦，瑞安笑了。重头戏来了。你知道我喜欢富家子弟什么吗？
Ryan Punches Luke in the face, hearted under the throwback, onto the table. Nothing. So that says that was awesome. Your asses, you're dead. That's it. See, thank you so much. I'm sorry. I mean, after a rough beginning, Wow.
瑞安一拳打在卢克的脸上，倒在复古桌子上，摔在桌子上。什么都没有。所以赛斯说这太棒了。你们这群混蛋，你们死定了。就是这样。听着，非常感谢。我很抱歉。我的意思是，经历了艰难的开局之后，哇。
After a rough beginning, Arnet killed it. Thank you. Thank you. Will Ferrell, I have a dumb fan question. Yeah. The fan is a really dumb question. Here we go from these two idiots.
在经历了一个艰难的开局后，阿奈特表现炸裂。谢谢。谢谢。威尔·法瑞尔，我有一个愚蠢的粉丝问题。是的。这位粉丝有一个非常愚蠢的问题。这两个白痴的问题来咯。
Oh, that is. Where, what is your favorite movie that you work down with? What's a favorite? Well, what is something that you love to do that really sticks out to you? You can't tell his favorite. We love his movies, right? We love Will's movies. Good luck, bro.
哦，那是。你在哪部合作过的电影中，你最喜欢哪一部？最喜欢的是什么？嗯，你最喜欢做什么，哪一部对你触动最深？你不能说出他的最爱。我们喜欢他的电影，对吧？我们喜欢威尔的电影。祝你好运，兄弟。
But what was the one that you just like had the most incredible experience? You were proud of the result, all of that kind of stuff. Well, blades of glory. Blades of glory, starring Will. Will, do you guys know how you really pronounce his last name? The wedge? Arnett.
但哪一部是你拥有最不可思议体验的？你为结果感到骄傲，诸如此类的事情。嗯，冰刀双人组（Blades of Glory）。《冰刀双人组》，由威尔主演。威尔，你们知道怎么正确发他的姓吗？The wedge？阿奈特（Arnett）。
Arnett. Arnett. Actually, he's right. I had to know. In Canada, he's Arnett. Arnett. Arnett. It's true.
阿奈特。阿奈特。其实，他是对的。我得知道。在加拿大，他是阿奈特。阿奈特。阿奈特。真的。
He moved down here and he started elongating it. What's the second reason? Is that true? Yeah. He knows that because my parents, my parents, my mom, my mom and dad are I was like no, it's will aren't it Whoa, whoa, whoa, really aren't it Guys this aren't it
他搬到这里后开始把音拉长了。第二个原因是什么？这是真的吗？是的。他知道这个因为我父母，我父母，我妈妈，我爸爸和我是——我当时想，不，那是威尔·阿耐特。哇，哇，哇，真的是阿耐特。伙计们，这是阿耐特。
Changes everything can I borrow your shades? Can I borrow your shades? It's gonna burn your shades gonna burn shade This changes everything yeah, so wait if your mom and dad introduced themselves to somebody, they would say, I am Mr. or Mrs. Arnet. Arnet. No, no, no. Now they say Arnet because they want to get the bump from being my parents. Yes. Oh, God.
这改变了一切，我能借你的墨镜吗？我能借你的墨镜吗？这会烤焦你的墨镜，会烤焦墨镜。这改变了一切，是的，等等，如果你的父母向别人做自我介绍，他们会说，我是阿奈特先生或太太。阿奈特。不，不，不。现在他们说阿奈特是因为他们想借用我父母的身份沾光。是的。哦，天哪。
That makes sense. Right. No, but they do. They want the juice. No, but they do say they do. My dad says, yeah, Jim Arnet. Well, yeah, we've talked about it. So he's been living a professional lie this whole time.
这就说得通了。对的。不，但他们确实这么做。他们想要那种名气。不，但他们确实说他们会的。我爸爸说，对，吉姆·阿奈特。好吧，是的，我们谈过这个。所以他这辈子都在过着一种职业谎言的生活。
It's true. It's true. So my question, uh, favorite man, which one makes you laugh the most? And it doesn't have to be about you, it could be somebody else in it or the one, which one? I heard Alphire kicking and screaming. I heard old school. I heard. Zoolander was pretty ridiculous. The one that makes me laugh the most is. I can't do the best. That's what I think is something really obscure.
这是真的。这是真的。所以我的问题，呃，最喜欢的男人，哪一个最让你发笑？而且不一定非得是你，可以是里面的其他人或者是哪一部，哪一部？我听说过《冰刀浪子》（Talladega Nights）和《疯狂圣诞假期》（Kicking and Screaming）。我听说过《老学校》（Old School）。我听说过。《超级名模》（Zoolander）挺荒谬的。最让我发笑的是。我选不出最好的一部。我觉得那是一个非常冷门的。
What's your, I would say, in terms of overall, if I had to pick one, it's Anchorman. Yeah. Oh, gosh. Just because, no. Oh, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, we love Anchorman.
你的，我要说，就整体而言，如果我必须选一部，那是《王牌播音员》（Anchorman）。是的。哦，天哪。仅仅因为，不。哦，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，那是一个，我们爱《王牌播音员》。
What was your show called again? What was the what? What was your show? My TV show? My TV show? No, your Broadway show. I promise this promise is. There was a wondering standing ovation for promises.
你的秀叫什么名字来着？什么叫什么？你的秀是什么？我的电视节目？我的电视节目？不，你的百老汇秀。我保证这个保证是。对《承诺》有一场起立鼓掌。
That's true. That's true. Not so much for Anchorman. Not so much for Anchorman. But that was like we were for promise. That's true. Not so much for ink. Not so much for ink for me. But that was like we were playing with the house's money. There was like, why are they letting us make this? Well, when you went and pitched that movie to what's his name?
那是真的。那是真的。对《王牌播音员》没那么多。对《王牌播音员》没那么多。但那就好像我们在用公司的钱在玩。就好像，他们为什么让我们拍这个？好吧，当你去向那个谁推销那部电影时？
Husband and wife, team, where the producer is in. Yes. Walter Parks? Yeah, right, right, right. And will, apparently, this is legendary stuff. Will walked in, he was wearing a huge, they were trying to pitch, get the money to make Anchorman, and you and Kay went in. Well, we had to go in for a lot.
夫妻档，制作人在里面的那个。是的。沃尔特·帕克斯（Walter Parks）？是的，对，对，对。而威尔，显然，这是传奇般的事情。威尔走进去时，戴着一顶巨大的，他们试图推销，筹集资金来拍《王牌播音员》，你和凯进去了。嗯，我们有很多事要进去谈。
We knew it was not looking good. Yeah. People just did, we're not getting the idea. And so we're like, let's just go and mess around and pitch around. And you had a huge foam cowboy hat. Yes. And in the middle, we all did cross multiple parts
我们知道情况看起来不太好。是的。人们只是，我们没能领会那个构思。所以我们觉得，不如就去胡闹一番，随便推销一下。然后你戴了一顶巨大的泡沫牛仔帽。是的。而在中间，我们所有人都经历了好几个部分
who's making the decision to make it. And there are people who are talking. And we'll stare them down. And then just interrupt it and said, I think I'm falling in love with you. I'm falling in love with you. I'm falling in love with you. We'll also came, we had an engagement party
是谁在做决定要拍它。还有人在说话。然后我们盯着他们看。然后突然打断并说，我想我爱上你了。我爱上你了。我爱上你了。威尔还来过，我们有一个订婚派对
years ago and we'll show it up, bringing a hat that said, I'm number one. To my, remember that? And you also, you had a hat, the Patriots had 19 or no? 19 or no. Yeah. Yeah.
几年前，威尔出现时带了一顶写着“我是第一”的帽子。给我的，还记得吗？你还有，你有一顶帽子，爱国者队19胜0负？19胜0负。是的。是的。
That you wore two Boston, to Amy's parents house. To Amy's parents house. Yeah. After they had just lost the Super Bowl, that's right. To go 18 and one. Because they made one. You know, they make those hats in case they win,
你戴着去了波士顿，去艾米的父母家。去艾米的父母家。是的。就在他们刚刚输掉超级碗之后，没错。战绩变成18胜1负。因为他们做了一个。你知道的，他们制作那些帽子以防他们赢了，
they make the hats of the team can put them on. And if they don't win, they destroy them or they send them to some other part of the world where they can use the hats. And so I have to do it. People say that about our merchandise, but yeah. Yes, yeah. So it said Patriots perfect season 19 and O.
他们制作球队可以戴的帽子。如果他们没有赢，他们就会销毁它们或者把它们送到世界上其他可以使用这些帽子的地区。所以我必须这么做。人们对我们的周边商品也这么说，但是的。是的，是的。所以上面写着爱国者队完美赛季19胜0负。
And a buddy mine got me one. And I wore it up to Boston Thanksgiving dinner. And I think Amy's dad was like, will, not funny, get that hat off. Oh, that is not fucking funny. Look at this guy, if I can choke, I have him canada. I'm hilarious, dude, Ashley, Bill Polar. I'm hilarious, dude. I love that you found a 19-to-no Patriots.
我一个哥们儿给我弄了一个。我戴着它去波士顿吃感恩节晚餐。我想艾米的爸爸当时就像是，威尔，不好笑，把那顶帽子脱下来。哦，这他妈一点都不好笑。看这家伙，如果我能噎住，我就会把他弄到加拿大去。我太搞笑了，老兄，说真的，比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我太搞笑了，老兄。我很高兴你找到了一顶19胜0负的爱国者队帽子。
I know, that's crazy. I think I still have it somewhere too. Yeah. So the- I lost the I'm number one half. Did you know I don't know what happened? It was a great one. But the so on SNL where you can pick a character,
我知道，这太疯狂了。我想我某个地方也还留着它。是的。所以——我把那顶“我是第一”的帽子弄丢了。你知道吗，我不知道怎么回事？那是一顶很棒的帽子。但是，在周六夜现场（SNL）你可以挑选一个角色，
write a character, and it only has to last three, four, five pages. So if it doesn't work, you never have to do it again. If it does work, you can repeat that character next week or with a film, you have to go make this full commitment into oftentimes a brand new character. Is that more scary for you that like, well, I can't change it now. I got to do 120 pages of this character over the course of a few months. How do you like the stakes of those two things? You're blond out.
写一个角色，它只需要维持三、四、五页的戏份。所以如果行不通，你再也不用演它了。如果行得通，你下周就可以重复那个角色，或者拍电影时，你得全身心地投入到一个通常是全新的角色中去。这会让你觉得更害怕吗，比如，好吧，我现在不能改了。在几个月的时间里，我得演这个角色120页的戏。你觉得这两者的风险哪个更大？你完全被震撼了。
You're burning! You are burning to look at that. This is your next interview. We've gone over. emoji thumbs up. Can't beat that. You can't beat that. Is it nerve-rack?
你在燃烧！你看那个简直燃起来了。这是你的下一个采访。我们超时了。大拇指表情符号。这没法比。这简直没法比。这让人神经紧张吗？
Oh, he's gone. I, you know, ignorance is bliss. Uh, I don't, you don't think about it. Yeah. For better or for worse. Charge ahead. Same stakes of doing one that lasts for one sketch versus a whole movie.
哦，他走了。我，你知道的，无知是福。呃，我不知道，你不会去想它。是的。不管好坏。勇往直前。演一个只持续一集小品和演一整部电影，面临的风险是一样的。
You're either picking up the debris later or somehow. Let me ask you this. You land on your feet and you're like, oh, somehow it. Let me ask you this. You land on your feet and you're like, oh, that worked. Let me ask you this. Have you ever done a film where you come in on the first day and you're doing one of these incredible characters that you do and you pull it off, you take huge swings, you always pull it off, am I wrong?
你要么以后去收拾残局，要么用某种方式。我问你这个。你站稳了脚跟，然后你会想，哦，不知怎么的。让我问你这个。你站稳了脚跟，然后你会想，哦，那行得通。让我问你这个。你有没有拍过这样一部电影：第一天进组，你在演那些你擅长的不可思议的角色之一，你成功了，你尝试了巨大的转型，你总是能成功，难道我错了吗？
I'm right. Have you ever had a director that doesn't have a great sense of humor that might go, huh, can I talk to you for a second? And then the very first day, they don't get it and they want you to make a big change. Has that ever happened? Luckily, that is not, yeah. I've feared pretty well in that department. But I have had those moments and we might have talked about it when we did the podcast. I don't remember
我是对的。你有没有遇到过一个没有什么幽默感的导演，他可能会走过来问：呃，我能跟你谈一会儿吗？然后在第一天，他们根本不理解，并希望你做出一个重大的改变。这种情况发生过吗？幸运的是，并没有，是的。我在那个部门表现得相当不错。但我确实有过那些时刻，我们可能在我们做播客的时候谈过这个。我不记得了
yesterday. A year ago. When did we do that? Almost two years ago. So many gummies between them. Oh I'm sure. I got six in me right now. That was the experience. Well the two dop kits. Yeah yeah. Dop kits. Uh oh. Get more dop kits. No, this self-freshing up cooking dop kits. Running low. But that was kind of the experience on Elf in the sense that I just finished doing Saturday Night Live where a lot of that stuff pushed the envelope that I just finished doing Saturday Night Live where a lot of that stuff pushed the envelope. Here I was doing this PG family Christmas movie.
昨天。一年前。我们是什么时候做的？将近两年前。它们之间有太多的软糖。哦，我确信。我身上现在有六个。那就是那次经历。好吧，两个多普工具包。是的，是的。多普工具包。哦，不。弄更多的多普工具包。不，这是自我翻新的烹饪多普工具包。快用完了。但这有点像拍《圣诞精灵》时的经历，因为我刚做完《周六夜现场》，那里有很多内容都在挑战极限，我刚做完《周六夜现场》，那里有很多内容都在挑战极限。在这里，我正在拍这部PG级的家庭圣诞电影。
Running around New York City in my yellow tites. Sitting in my little, not even a half-banger trailer in front of the little electric heater. You're right. And just looking in the mirror, going, so it was you that had the self doubt. It wasn't foul for all of it. This isn't it, huh?
穿着我的黄色紧身衣在纽约市跑来跑去。坐在我那个甚至都算不上半截的拖车里，前面有个小电暖器。你说得对。然后只是照着镜子，心想，原来是你对自己产生了怀疑。并不是所有这些都是假的。这不是真的，对吧？
I was just like, this could be it. Wait, you know what, that's a good point. And instead, it's a big second. It's a tight second to it's a wonderful life as the best Christmas movie ever. Yeah, right? But that's a great point. So it's a big swing you's a tight second to, it's a wonderful life, is the best Christmas movie ever. Yeah, right? But that's a great point. So it's a big swing you're doing this character of Elle,
我当时就觉得，这可能就是了。等等，你知道吗，这是一个很好的观点。相反，它是一个伟大的第二名。它紧随《生活多美好》之后，堪称史上最佳圣诞电影。是的，对吧？但这真是个好观点。所以这是一个巨大的转型，你正在扮演埃尔这个角色，
and you have, that's the thing is, you have no fucking idea. If it's gonna work, we're people are gonna laugh. But did you feel pressure from being on, this being your first movie, and did you feel like all eyes are new? Let's see if this guy's got it. Well, a little bit, and like I said,
而且你，这就是问题所在，你他妈的一点也不知道。这到底行不行得通，人们会不会笑。但是你当时会有压力吗？因为这是你的第一部电影，你有没有觉得所有人的目光都在盯着你？让我们看看这家伙到底有没有两下子。嗯，有一点，就像我说的，
it was an old school was in the can, but it hadn't come out yet. And really? So it was just like. For my sister Tracy in the can, man. Yeah. Just for people who don't know it in the can, man. In the can, man, shot, but not yet released.
《老学校》已经拍完了，但还没上映。真的吗？所以就像是。为了我妹妹翠西，拍完了，伙计。是的。只是为了让那些不知道的人知道，拍完了，伙计。拍完了，伙计，拍好了，但还没上映。
That's right. And I don't want to say that, because I don't want to make you mad, because I know about your hair trigger. Oh. Temper. But Tracy almost got more applause than they could be. I don't think I did it.
没错。我不想这么说，因为我不想惹你生气，因为我知道你那火爆的脾气。哦。暴脾气。但翠西得到的掌声几乎比他们能得到的还要多。我觉得我没做到。
Don't think I did it. Don't lock it up. Don't, don't fucking, don't do it. I am going on such a bender tonight. I'm gonna run around those monuments with a spear gun, fueled on cocaine, screaming trace's name. When you used to be addicted to day-old seafood or natural horror, don't get me going. Day-old lobster.
觉得我没做到。别把它锁起来。别，别他妈的，别这么做。我今晚要大喝特喝一场。我要带着鱼枪在那些纪念碑周围跑来跑去，靠着可卡因的刺激，大喊着翠西的名字。当你过去对隔夜海鲜或自然恐怖片上瘾时，别让我开始。隔夜龙虾。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I get it. But yeah, so old school was in the... Yeah, so yeah, that was just such a huge... And James Conn, Jamie Conn, who was fantastic, and we're so lucky to get him
对。对。对。我懂。但话又说回来，所以《老学校》在……是的，所以，是的，那真的是太巨大了……还有詹姆斯·凯恩，杰米·凯恩，他太棒了，我们能请到他真是太幸运了
another moment at a premiere, a comment, he was like, great job. I got to tell you. Because he didn't think so during, he said, I thought every day you were way over the top. You know? And you could see it on his face in the movie, but it works for the character.
首映式上的另一个时刻，有个评论，他说，干得好。我得告诉你。因为他在拍摄期间并不这么认为，他说，我以为你每天都表现得太过火了。你知道吗？你可以在电影中他的脸上看出来，但这很适合这个角色。
And so I think he literally was like, what is this guy doing? You probably fired his agent six times during that shoot. But yeah, so that was like prime example of... It's all about process. Don't try to judge it too much. Just keep plowing ahead because you could look at it later and be like, oh, that was working the whole time. Well, your commitment is just, we're so lucky.
所以我想他当时字面意思就是：这家伙在搞什么鬼？在拍摄期间，你大概把他的经纪人炒了六次吧。不过，是的，那绝对是一个典型的例子……这一切都关于过程。不要过分去评判它。只需继续奋力前行，因为你以后回看时会觉得，哦，原来那一直都很有用。好吧，你的投入简直是，我们太幸运了。
Yeah. Let's take commitment is just, we're so lucky. Yeah. Let's thank Will Ferrell, everybody. Yeah. Thank you, guys. Thanks, guys. You're the best. You're the best. You're the best.
是的。让我们感谢对演出的投入，我们太幸运了。是的。谢谢威尔·法瑞尔，大家。是的。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你们，伙计们。你们是最棒的。你们是最棒的。你们是最棒的。
You're the best. You're the best. Keep that. I want to give you something now. Keep that. Keep that. Keep that. Right this way, William. Do I leave? I I leave yeah, okay You're already on the phone. He's already on the phone. Look at the string on the back.
你们是最棒的。你们是最棒的。留着那个。我现在想给你点东西。留着那个。留着那个。留着那个。这边请，威廉。我要离开吗？我，我离开，好吧。你已经在打电话了。他已经在打电话了。看后面的线。
He's gonna cigarette butt. And he left this cigarette butt. He left this cigarette butt. You guys got Will Phill. Yeah. How... Nice job. I just thought for our first show,
他要拿烟蒂。他留下了这个烟蒂。他留下了这个烟蒂。你们请到了威尔·法瑞尔。耶。多棒啊……干得漂亮。我只是觉得对于我们的第一个节目，
I wanted to have somebody who's a friend of the show, and he was the first person that we actually interviewed. He wasn't our first broadcast, but the first guy that we interviewed. And I just wanted to have it to be like a friendly, you know what I mean? Make it be like a home game. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
我想要找一个节目的老朋友，而他正是我们真正采访的第一个人。他不是我们第一个广播的嘉宾，但却是我们采访的第一个人。我只是想让它变得像个朋友，你知道我的意思吗？让它就像是一场主场比赛。对，对，肯定的。
I mean, I meant what I said, like I'm such a, like everybody is such a massive fan. He's never not funny on a talk show appearance, on a movie, on a TV show, on anything he's so prepared. By the way, and he came, oh, this is hilarious. He's holding us, oh my God, let's have that. Holding us. She's got a bunch of buys for us.
我是说，我是认真的，就像我是一个，每个人都是他的超级粉丝。他在脱口秀节目、电影、电视节目或任何事情中从来没有不好笑过，他准备得太充分了。顺便说一句，他来了，哦，这太搞笑了。他拿着我们，哦天哪，让我们看看那个。拿着我们。她给我们准备了一堆小物件。
This is incredibly helpful right now. Yeah. Yeah. Because this is, we need to start thinking of how we're going to get out of here. And let's see here. Let's, well, I'll tell you what, so you guys take a look and I'll take a look and then I was going to talk with some more nice things about well. No, no, no, I know, but you can upload this and then back.
这现在对我们太有帮助了。是的。是的。因为这是，我们需要开始考虑怎么离开这里了。让我们看看这个。让我们，好吧，我告诉你，你们看看，我也看看，然后我要跟你们多聊聊关于威尔的一些好事情。不，不，不，我知道，但你可以上传这个然后回来。
Put it right there so that the audience can't see. Huh, and they don't know. This is really cheating though. It's called the endless goodbye. I feel like if we use one of these too, we're going to get sued. Oh, good point. Good point. So anyway, so he shows up.
把它放在那里，这样观众就看不到了。哈，他们还不知道。这其实是在作弊。这叫无尽的道别。我觉得如果我们也用其中一个，我们会被起诉的。哦，好主意。好主意。所以不管怎样，他出现了。
I was going to say, I was going to say he's never not funny everything he does and the commitment, the fact that he brought us these script, like he worked on scripts to do for us tonight, and then all of the other bits that he came out with, like that work, like you have to write that and think about that. So nice.
我要说的是，我要说的是，他做任何事都从不失手，而且那种投入，他给我们带了这些剧本——他今晚专门为我们写了剧本，还有他拿出的所有其他桥段，比如那些作品，你必须去写并去思考这些。太棒了。
So always prepared and nice is kind of work. Super. Applause. He, super, super funny. You know, when we, when we did, blaze a glory, the first thing I, we, no, no, no, no, no, no. And it was like the first big movie that I did coming out of arrest of development.
所以永远准备充分又友好，这简直是一种工作。超级。掌声。他，超级，超级搞笑。你知道，当我们，当我们制作《荣誉之刃》时，第一件事我，我们，不，不，不，不，不，不。这就像是我拍完《发展受阻》后拍的第一部大电影。
And Will, thank you. And Will, oh wait, really quick, who went to the premiere of that? Albrechted? I know, Blades of Glory. I didn't. You did. Were be arrested? I know, I've played the glory. I didn't. You did? Were you there? How is that for you?
威尔，谢谢你。还有威尔，哦等等，等一下，谁去那部电影的首映礼了？阿尔布雷希特？我知道，《荣誉之刃》。我没去。你去了。我们被捕了吗？我知道，我演了《荣誉之刃》。我没去。你去了吗？你在那儿感觉怎么样？
Oh, you were? Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Jason got mad for real again today about the fact
哦，你在？哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。今天杰森又真的生气了，因为
that Sean and I have vacation together a few times. But we love you. Really? Yeah, you're invited. You're invited. We're invited. You're invited. We're invited. But what does good thing is, like, of course, Will is hilarious.
肖恩和我一起度过假好几次。但我们爱你的。真的吗？是的，你被邀请了。你被邀请了。我们被邀请了。你被邀请了。我们被邀请了。但好的一面是，就像，当然，威尔非常搞笑。
And he's, like you said, super well prepared. Always does a funny bit. Always does something that you wouldn't think of. That's a special. Yeah, really special, interesting. But on top of it, he's the senior. He's the guy. He's already making these incredibly funny, great movies.
而且他就像你说的，准备得超级充分。总能想出搞笑的桥段。总能做出一些你想不到的事情。那真是个特例。是的，非常特别，有趣。但最重要的是，他是前辈。他是那个大腕。他已经在拍摄这些极其搞笑、棒极了的电影了。
And I've known him for a few years, but getting on the set where that's his milieu, if you will, like that's where, and he was so gracious to everybody in the cast and me by being, you know, he was just always very generous. Well, that's the sign of a big superstar. Yeah. Like, you can't be an asshole. Yeah. I mean, you know, if you have to treat everybody equal, just work hard and be nice.
我已经认识他几年了，但是走进那个属于他的领域（如果你愿意这么说的话）的片场，那就是他的地盘，他对剧组的每个人和我都非常体贴，你知道的，他总是非常慷慨。嗯，这就是超级巨星的风范。是的。总之，你不能当混蛋。我的意思是，你知道的，如果你必须平等对待每个人，那就努力工作并保持善良。
Well, I have that up in my office. Just work hard and be nice. And one day, one day you're going to do it. And we can't wait. We really can't. This is... I love you, too. Yeah.
好吧，我的办公室里就挂着这个。努力工作并保持善良。总有一天，总有一天你会成功的。我们都迫不及待了。我们真的迫不及待了。这是……我也爱你。是的。
I love you. Oh, you're the one who saw it. Thank you. We, uh... That was a funny script. Really funny. We love Sean, too. Oh, you were checking this out?
我爱你。哦，原来你是那个看到的人。谢谢。我们，呃……那是个有趣的剧本。真的非常搞笑。我们也爱肖恩。哦，你在查看这个吗？
I'm not gonna look at those. Okay. That's a great question. We're not gonna take any those. Okay. We should write together. I want to write a message. That's a great question. We're not gonna take any more questions from the audience other than have you still, have you watched the rest of the development yet? Sure.
我才不看那些呢。好吧。这是个好问题。我们不会接受任何这些。好吧。我们应该一起写作。我想写一条信息。这是个好问题。除了“你看了《发展受阻》剩下的部分了吗”之外，我们不会再回答观众的任何问题。当然。
Yeah. What character does he play? Yeah. He played, remember I call it Job. No, no, no, I call it Gob. Gob. But I call it Gob. It is what?
是的。他演的是什么角色？是的。他演的，还记得我叫他Job吗。不，不，不，我叫他Gob。Gob。但我叫它Gob。到底是什么？
It's Job, yeah. And? It's your, yeah. And? Wait, no, you are... Well, give me the first letter of your name. No, no, no. Just the first letter of his word. Damn. Oh, my God.
是Job，对。还有？你的，对。还有？等等，不对，你是……好吧，告诉我你名字的首字母。不，不，不。只要他那个词的首字母。该死。哦，天哪。
Can we talk about word-o? Oh, let's do it. And one of the other things is our big joke is like, oh great, yeah, send us your screen grabs a wordle. And also tell us what you think about the Beatles documentary. But I can't wait. And how is your work situation like succession? It's not.
我们能谈谈Wordle吗？哦，我们来谈谈吧。其中一件事我们的笑话是，哦太好了，把你们Wordle的截图发给我们。顺便告诉我们你们对披头士纪录片怎么看。但我等不及了。你的工作情况怎么样，像《继承之战》吗？才不是。
But here, so we did wordle for the first time yesterday on the plane. And so, of course, we were making fun of it. We hadn't done it. So we did wordle for the first time yesterday on the plane and So of course we were making fun of it. We had it done it. Of course. It's great and then today today Jay goes All right, I can't wait for the next one. We're like no, it's only once a day. It's only once a day How does that everybody gets the same word? Yeah, right? So how are you not like? Seeing that on Twitter at the top of the day? I don't, how is this catching on? Because people have other stuff to do. Yeah.
但在这里，所以我们昨天在飞机上第一次玩了Wordle。所以，当然，我们一直在拿它开玩笑。我们之前没玩过。所以我们昨天在飞机上第一次玩Wordle，所以当然我们在拿它开玩笑。我们还没玩过。当然。这太棒了，然后今天，今天杰说：好吧，我等不及下一局了。我们说：不，一天只有一次。一天只有一次。怎么会每个人都拿到同一个词？对吧？所以你怎么能不在推特置顶上看到这个呢？我不知道，这怎么会流行起来？因为人们还有别的事要做。
Oh. By the way, all these buys are, thank you for the effort, they're all useless. They're not, they're not like, oh, I guess some of them do work. No, that one's good. That one's pretty good. You know what, what is good?
哦。顺便说一句，所有这些小物件，谢谢你们的努力，它们全都没用。它们不是，它们不是那种，哦，我猜有些确实管用。不，那个挺好的。那个挺不错的。你知道吗，什么挺好？
You know what, I went on my favorite. Here we go, now that's Sean right there. one's pretty good. You know what? You know what? Here we go. Now, that's Sean right there. He's about to do his body. He just... He's just the whole of that one. He's just the whole of that one. He's just the whole of that one.
你知道吗，我去了我最喜欢的。我们开始吧，肖恩就在那儿。那个挺不错的。你知道吗？你知道吗？我们开始吧。看，肖恩就在那儿。他正准备展现他的身材。他刚……他简直包揽了那个。他简直包揽了那个。他简直包揽了那个。
I can break. God, you know what? It's going to be the worst. You know what? One of my favorite characters that will... What was it? What was it? Will Ferrell played.
我要崩溃了。天哪，你知道吗？这绝对是最糟糕的。你知道吗？我最喜欢的威尔饰演的角色之一……
It was Zintaladegan Naito. What was his name? Call? Ricky. Bye-bye! Bye-bye! Bye-bye! Thank you! Thank you!
那是《塔拉迪加之夜》。他叫什么名字？叫？里奇。拜拜！拜拜！拜拜！谢谢！谢谢！
Thank you, Washington DC. Thank you! Smart. Bloss. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grandterry. Smart. Last. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，华盛顿特区。谢谢！聪明。布洛斯。SmartLess是由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Grandterry 100%有机且纯手工制作的。聪明。无趣。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。